Good morning sleepyhead!
Good morning good evening good afternoon!
Are you ready to play puzzle game with me?
You can already see the first one.
Okay, so in order to link to it,
I'm going to have to constantly close the game,
well close it from stream, so actually close.
Okay, but I will link you this website.
It should have a little insert, so you can name yourself if you like.
You can do something humorous.
But we're just doing a test.
This is testing 250 pieces an image.
We'll just take a moment...
Yeah, that's not even names!
You're just spamming!
That was so quick!
So we're just testing if you guys are able to
figure out the 250 pieces.
I've got some cam music on in the background.
It's just a chill day today.
I've got a few funny images, but this is just the start,
so I just wanted to see how you guys do.
I'm going to put Azura together,
because Azura's got teal in her hair.
I can see AC's got blue over here,
so I'm just going to drag her over here.
Hello! Good morning good evening good afternoon!
I'm having to play Super Dipper safe.
My dad has fully come down with a cold.
Not me in the middle with my little scored eyes!
Um...
Mumme!
My...
Yeah, my dad's unfortunately come down with a flu.
I actually had to go to the pharmacy yesterday for him.
And like I explained what's wrong,
and they were like if he's not...
If he still...
He felt dizzy,
but he took some strong sleeping medication
that he got from the pharmacy,
and they warned him like they don't use too much of it.
But I don't know, he like phoned me after stream,
like I was only in the other room,
but he was too weak to like come out.
Um...
And he was like I feel dizzy,
so like I ran,
I got ready, went to the pharmacy,
and the lady behind the counter was like
unfortunately we can't do anything for that kind of thing,
if it's not better in 24 hours,
like go with the doctor.
So I'm currently quarantining myself from my dad,
but the problem is we're sharing a space
and I really don't want to get sick.
Um...
So I had take away,
and he's had subway.
Just to fill his tongue.
Oh, there's the top of my peril.
My head, please.
I can see that's my shell,
but it's not fitting anywhere.
Wait, that's my shell, is it not?
Oh no, that's my hair piece.
These are my two shells.
Where did I go?
I had my eyes here so I couldn't go.
Oh, there's me.
Okay, my shell goes here somewhere.
And then this is my other shell over here.
I'm gonna move these out of the room.
I'm not sure that they are.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
I'm stealing pieces from people's hands.
I'm sorry.
Right, this is a zero sleep,
because I can see that purple from anywhere.
But it's just a really chill day.
Um, nice and easy.
Um, I am...
Oh, you can't see,
because I'm a big hair, hold on.
Above, because I want to redact it,
you're redacted, redacted.
Thank you for censoring yourselves, Reeflings.
You guys are very smart when it comes to streaming.
You guys don't give yourself enough credit
for how smart or cool you are.
Um, I can see Mercy's head is being formed up here.
Right, someone has gone for the old top method.
So if we can drag a zero up here and Mercy up here,
we might be in somewhere.
Right, I can see that's a part of my shell.
Someone popped that up here.
Oh wait, I'll move a little bit.
I'm the dumbest Reefing love mummy.
Wait, maybe I should go this side today.
I don't normally go this side.
Or did I just need to be a wee bit smaller today?
Yeah, you can talk in game 2 if you want.
But yeah, I think he's going to get better soon.
He says he feels better, but he coughed up like phlegm
or something.
I can't remember what it's called.
Surprised we didn't have a mate,
a mate hunt or a mate ox, huh?
I don't know, you guys play so well in games together.
I think someone said a way of the go,
they were like, normally like whenever a streamer
does something multiplayer that could be easily ruined,
like the autism gets a bit of a chat,
but someone said something along the lines of
like, oh mummy's just so happy to play
and see us that it never comes out.
I feel very loved when we can do goofy things like this together.
Why is my eye out of alignment?
Oh you guys forget, it's 250,
it's 250 pieces too easy.
The next unlock is going to be my schedule for next week.
So you have to figure out what my schedule is.
Let me get really clear.
Yeah, you can see the goods.
I can't wait for the 10k stream.
Strony's bathtub, yeah, yeah, yeah, but
I'm done with the re-
message deleted by Strony's followers.
Family portrait, oh, oh dear.
Someone accidentally did it.
This is emi's hair, oh sorry.
We have a few issues, we have a few technical errors,
don't worry we're getting there in the end.
It's so efficient.
But yeah, the next one you're going to unlock,
I'm going to have to hide the screen,
because you're going to unlock my schedule for next week.
But should I make it 500 pieces?
I don't know.
It keeps moving the puzzle your mum's just like.
Okay I'll do 500 for my schedule
and then I will talk over what we're playing next week together.
Are doing next week.
Why is this music so emotional for no reason?
I just typed in copyright free Zelda.
Whoever's moving the puzzle please stop doing that.
You're making it a bit harder to complete
and we've got quite a few images to get through.
I have behind the scenes images
that have never seen the light of day before.
So I'm very excited to show that.
So I don't know what you guys are going to react to.
Use control to lock it in please gang.
What?
What and then release?
Why you did it?
Okay so this was just an easy one to get you started.
These are the emotes of eyes.
You guys have put in the worst thing.
I'm in the way of it.
I just made it nice and easy.
I can't join because I'm on phone.
I'm sorry.
It's just a casual stream snipe.
This isn't intense or anything.
We're literally sitting making puzzles.
Right let's replay.
What's the replay going to look like?
Okay so this is me when I load it in.
I'm not jumping away from us.
Oh that was so fast.
Okay I think you guys are going to need like 500 pieces.
Because that was far too easy for you.
I don't want to sit on chat.
Sorry I'm sitting on chat if I'm over here.
Sorry.
Excuse me.
Just coming through.
Okay you want a thousand pieces?
Oh I'm not sure about that.
Hold on.
I think I need to...
Oh no.
Do I need to do a new room every time?
I think I need to give a new room every time.
Room settings.
Oh dear.
Oh dear oh dear.
I think I need to create a new room darlings.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Next one is my schedule.
And we can do a thousand pieces?
Are you sure you want a thousand pieces?
I don't think we can because of the background on it.
I'm going to do 750 pieces.
Okay 700 pieces a schedule test.
I think...
Oh it's already just made the thing.
Oh this looks difficult.
I'm not sure.
50 pieces might be too much for us reeflings.
I know.
Look I'm really testing.
Pet pie says 750 pieces puzzle.
Puzzle and it's my schedule.
Rollie legend.
Thank you for becoming a member for over a month.
I was able to...
Did that work?
I swear if it does.
He's not.
This one's not the easiest.
I'll just make sure you guys are joining me.
Or did I link the wrong thing?
I think I linked the right thing.
Yeah this one's 750 pieces.
I'll wait until you guys are in in.
Or is it not working?
I don't see you guys able to join the list.
If we all work together it'll be fine.
I'm in?
That doesn't display anyone.
It just says me the big fish.
We're in?
Is mine broken?
Is it moving?
Is it moving for anyone?
We're dragging pieces.
Refresh?
Oh.
Huh.
Oh are you in?
You're here.
Yay!
Okay good luck figuring out my thing.
I will give you a hint.
The ginger goes to the left of the schedule because that's what the photo is.
Any skin colour goes to the left because again that's what the photo is.
I don't know why they didn't like that.
God my joke wasn't seen.
I'm sorry wait what was your joke?
We're in let's go.
Oh wait hold on let me get out of the way of the chat.
I'm always in the way I think I'm gonna have to...
I can't believe it but I'm standing to the side.
Are you guys okay if I cover up chat a little bit?
We're in let's go.
End the stream straight up.
And it...
Well let's just see.
My pintas.
My saw.
That's actually really good.
Oh I wish that was the tail.
I don't know what the tail is.
Let's go.
This puzzle is long like a reflexant.
Oh why am I getting smaller?
Don't be shy.
Oh my god how have you put together an eye already?
That's insane.
You guys are too good at this.
Like unironically you guys are too good.
And then you get to figure...
Oh!
Not you guys already figuring out plop plop plop.
Is it in my schedule?
All I see is plop plop plop yeah.
Oh hold on I've not got live chat on.
It's horrible.
Quality mate viewers are discussing a game idea
where multiple people collaboratively solve
a very large jigsaw puzzle.
That is the most accurate one I've seen so far.
No?
Look how efficient you guys are.
Really color coding down here.
What color coordination of the purple?
The edge pieces?
Someone's going to absolutely ham on the edge pieces.
Of course that's the first discernible thing
that comes together.
Oh!
And more of the words are coming together.
What do you think it says?
It says get educated.
Get educated.
Plop plop plop.
Refling's the master of edge truly.
We live in a society.
I can see my belt coming together.
Am I supposed to be doing this with you guys?
Or am I allowed to like commentate
as if this is like a super MLG game?
And the reflings are coming in clutch.
We have the border of the south.
We have a border north and left.
Oh, okay.
Hold on a minute.
We've got a whole quadrant.
We have the shape over here.
And of course I'm covering it up.
I'll go in the middle.
As we can see to my right.
Well, it's my right.
Your left, I guess.
Look at me.
It's in there.
And we're getting...
It's all coming together.
There's like no good area to go.
Isn't that amazing?
I hate navigating.
I'll just be all the way down here.
Okay.
Thank you for all your hard work.
Refling.
Hi.
Hi, Johnny.
Hi, Refling.
Good morning.
We're playing a ridiculous game
where we put puzzles together.
But the reward for doing the puzzle,
you'll never guess what it is.
As you get to see what my schedule is.
For this week.
Oh, I see it.
I see one.
Epic Gamer, thank you for coming
to member and to support.
Oh, no.
My freaking stream elements isn't up.
So I can't see the history.
Oh, and I'm just really big.
It's one of those streams where things
aren't working the way they ought to be.
Thank you, Gamberly Legends.
I made the month membership today.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
And then Epic Gamer, thank you for coming to member.
I appreciate it.
All membership streams resume on the last week.
And I will make up for any missed streams.
I promise.
Oh, it's all coming together.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, how to...
Check it out.
You can see it coming together.
We've got weekly here.
Oh, someone had it.
It was like that.
I don't want to interfere too much.
I feel like I'm going to sabotage it.
Oh, no.
Is this game what I think it is?
Hold on a minute.
Oh, no.
Okay.
We've got the games together.
Oh, the games are coming together.
Oh, we've got get educated, get educated,
get educated, get educated.
Plop, plop, plop.
We've got a supermarket simulator.
What remains of Edith Finch?
That was a recommended game.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Kent Quispy.
I'm blue, diva, diva, diva.
Wait, why'd I forget the tune of that?
I'm blue, abadi, abadi, and I'm blue.
I would die if I would beat off a guy.
Thank you for the membership extended.
I have no idea.
I still want to say
about that.
I'm like, yes, membership extended.
Oh, what do I see?
Ring for adventure with a heart rate monitor.
Well, I've got a collab with someone.
Who have I got a collab with?
Oh, I'm sorry, Refling.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, down here.
Yeah, yeah, chase each other.
Chase each other.
Yay, you did it.
You did it.
Thanks for subscribing again.
And subscriptions all over you.
If I were green, I would die.
Hey, Stony, we can see the finished puzzle
in the top left corner.
Oh, no.
No, don't cheat.
It's supposed to be a surprise.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it's a cheat sheet at all.
It's supposed to be a surprise.
No.
Wait, you guys hear the whole time?
You just let me be happy in my ignorance?
Okay, I'll be happy in my ignorance.
Like it's me.
And I'm going with my little heart pose.
I love that pose.
I might unironically ready to commission that pose.
Like with my hand forward and then the other one like...
Yeah.
The only problem is this bit here,
it gets impossible.
That's why I was worried about doing a thousand pieces.
Because in it, it's just darkness.
There's literally no logic to this section whatsoever.
I mean, the best I can do is like just try and force it.
Oh, sorry.
I don't know who that was, but sorry.
Wait, what, Mummy?
You will play Sukiya?
Maybe?
So every beat you were hit,
like remember when Sukiya came out
and everyone was going fucking...
Oh, oh, ah, ah, ape shit over it?
And I was like, you know what?
I want to see what the big deal is.
And apparently it's just a short and sweet game.
There's nothing too hard about it or nothing.
Whoa, Sukiya?
Isn't that Sukiya?
Suka?
Se'u?
Eka?
Um...
Mods...
Saw his...
Jiggle his soul.
Suika!
Se'u...
What did I say?
Se'u-kiya.
Sukiya.
Danlos by the Ring Fit...
The Ring Fit Adventure Squad record?
You know it, boo-boo!
I don't know what the endurance thing is, but...
Right, we do have a lot of...
No, this is where it gets difficult.
Right, we have a date.
We've got the 18th, so...
Uh, what's the day's date?
15...
So it'd be 16, 17, 18.
Um...
So...
Uh, oh no, it says Wednesday.
Okay, so we need to find Monday.
That's Tuesday.
Alright, we've got Monday here.
Um, so we can start with Monday and Tuesday,
and then we can start putting the games in the order...
that they...
start in.
I've got a date with Momaya, later, Virgin.
Are you holding on to a date?
No, you know.
No, there it is.
Look, it's on the move.
So Monday needs to go, like...
somewhere here.
I don't know where, but somewhere here.
Sorry, Strontium.
My pre-order can't handle the puzzle website,
so I can't play along without your stream lag and heavy.
I'll have to spectate.
I'm so sorry.
Aw, don't worry.
I'm sorry that, um...
I thought this would be a relatively easy one
to, like, stream snipe on.
But I know not all PCs are built equally.
That's okay.
Now this one, the time and then the dates
is gonna be a really hard section
because I always stream at the same time.
I'm not sure how easy it's gonna be.
I'm just trying to see if there's anything obvious.
Now there is a bit of pink text.
Ooh, sorry.
There is a bit of pink text.
Where do I need some sort of purple hue on this side?
Is there anything with a purple hue?
Oh, here!
This is the very piece I've been needing.
Ta-da!
I'm just so smart.
See, I helped!
I did one!
Turn off GPU rendering.
Stony please.
Suki again.
Call it Suika.
Suika.
Oh!
Aw.
You found it out now.
Drawing gen 2 suggestions.
I kept my word.
Oh no!
Did I just take my meds?
Hello?
Hello, reflings?
Did I just take my meds?
Oh no!
Hold on.
Did I need a refresh?
Refresh?
There's no refresh.
Oh no, we're back.
We're back.
I was like,
still there.
Okay, we weren't real.
No, don't say that.
I think it's sad enough in Elden Ring when we finished our boss
and then you guys despawned instantly.
A repopulation.
Whoa, did I just take my meds?
I don't take my meds for you.
Right, we've got Monday.
So Monday has to go.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, I guess not.
Oh, there's a Wednesday.
Well, we can bring Wednesday under Tuesday.
Oh, sorry.
No?
I'm trying to help,
but I think I'm making a worse refling.
Right, where's Tuesday?
Tuesday's here.
I'm gonna bring...
I think the lag isn't helping.
Oh no, wait, what?
Where's Wednesday?
Where's Wednesday not just here?
I'm gonna go crazy.
Oh, there's Wednesday.
No?
No, there's more wait now.
There's Friday if I'm Friday.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
Right, where's the rest of Friday though?
He took my piece and left.
No, I'm here, I'm here.
Where's my thigh?
Look for a really...
Oh, there's Friday.
I found Friday.
Oh, so wait, someone's doing something down here with it.
Where's my thigh?
There's like a big chunk of my thigh missing.
I'm gonna go look for it.
Hold on.
Look for a really pale piece.
I don't see it.
Oh no.
I lost it.
Someone's holding on to my thigh piece.
I'm eating the thigh.
I'm sucking on it right now.
Right.
Hold on, what's going on here?
Oh, this is a bottom section of one of these.
I can see it.
Where is that thigh?
I genuinely can't find that thigh piece.
It would be so bright compared to all the others.
Eclan.
What?
Hold it.
Who's holding that in red?
You know I can kick whoever is trolling.
If you just trolling, I am going to kick you.
I'm not.
I'm not here for the troll.
I just want to have fun and play puzzle.
They chopped too hard.
It's not missing.
What, you guys saw it?
I can't see it.
Okay.
One second.
I don't know what it's going to come up with when I block someone.
Sorry, but please don't troll, darling.
We're just here to have fun.
I am blocked.
I will kick from games.
Please don't troll.
I'm just trying to have fun, goobers.
Oh, someone found the thigh piece.
Wow, look at my juicy thighs.
And look at this.
I've got like a little armpit here.
And I've got my eyes and my little shells.
And my little spikes here.
I love my little spikes.
I love my spikes that come like here because it's very, very cuttlefish-esque.
And then my little spikes here, which is also cuttlefish-esque.
Is it that?
Hmm.
Sorry, I think I keep accidentally moving it.
I'm not sure.
I see the shells.
I see all the-
It's going to be so hard to do these ones.
They're like impossible to decipher from one another.
I'm so sorry.
I just heard my dad blow his nose.
Sorry, I just heard my dad blow his nose.
He's not very well.
Mummy's left ball?
What are your names?
Stronny's armpit?
You guys are ridiculous.
Stronny's building?
Building what?
What am I making?
It's my question.
Hi, everyone.
Hi, replay.
Good morning.
Oh, well, you guys are doing it.
You put together my schedule.
Yeah, these color pieces are going to be a bit more difficult.
Oh, I did it.
I helped a little bit.
Oh, hold on.
I'm just going to try it in all this space.
Oh, I just connected two pieces together.
Oh, I think I saw where it matched.
Yes.
We're doing it.
Reflings, we're doing it.
If we just force it, then it works.
It just works.
I know you shouldn't really force things in a tight small hole,
but yeah, I think it works.
Reflings strong together.
I'm excited to get slapped this week.
Best part of the art is the drawing being out, yeah.
Let's see what I was doing.
Maybe one up here.
Yeah, I ain't got that.
I don't have the reaction time to see who's doing that to ban them.
I feel like you guys are all getting frustrated with one another.
Mod's a precious man still.
Right, we do have like one...
Oh, no, I lost it.
Oh, I found it.
I was worried about that.
Oh, sorry.
I'm touching the same piece as someone else's.
Sorry, refling, I just...
Me and this refling just held hands.
Later.
Here?
No, not there.
Maybe that one?
I'm starting to feel that we might be getting frustrated at one another
and shaking the puzzle a little bit.
I'm just getting that slight indication.
I'm not sure if my theory is founded at all.
But I think, perhaps...
I've locked this thing seven times.
I can't focus.
Oh, my connection!
No!
My connection's gone again!
I think if you move around too much, it's killing the thingy.
Hydration checked.
We are so cool.
I mean, you can tell what I'm doing, right?
I think we know what we're doing.
What should I...
Maybe, wait, next time I'll make it, I'll see if I can like lock it or something.
I don't know.
Oh, no, my connection.
It's trying its best, refling.
Oh!
Oh, it's back.
Ta-da!
Oh, look out.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
Did you do it?
Oh, sorry.
Well, guys.
Yay!
It's my schedule for the week!
That's right, I put you to work for it.
When other VTubers hand it to you so willingly,
I raised your IQ levels by doing the puzzle.
Yatta!
Okay, so for next week's schedule,
I'm drawing your nasty Gen 2 suggestions.
I already know I'm going to get a slim girl.
I'm going to have to sit and actually develop her.
And we get to name them as well.
I asked Mercy.
I'm going to give her a sister.
I had five hours sleep,
but speaking of less sleep,
is her still awake, I think?
Hm.
Monk is.
Or maybe she's asleep, I don't know.
She might be asleep and it was an old message I read, but...
Yes, we are going to draw Gen 2 together.
I have to do your suggestions.
Mercy was very kind.
I asked her,
Oh no, we got kicked!
Okay, we got kicked, that's fine.
Scores!
Oh my God, let's see who does the most.
Hostrooms can't be kicked now.
Force anonymous restrictions, game mode.
How autistic are you?
Pieces will be neatly arranged,
appeasing the autists?
We got kicked, that's rude.
I think I did self destruct,
that's why I just in case.
Oh wait,
now I need to actually put up my schedule on screen
to talk about, hold on.
Wait, I need to put my schedule up one second,
I'm sorry.
One moment,
okay, I need to talk about my schedule.
Boom!
Oh, well, yeah.
It's a bit bigger than I was anticipating.
Okay, there we go.
This is my schedule for next week.
So yes,
tomorrow,
Mercy gave me the basis of what she used
on her alternative design and stuff.
And then the day after,
I am making a PowerPoint presentation
on my special interests,
and you're getting educated along the way.
Okay?
Yes,
I'm going to teach you things
and stuff that I like,
so you're being forced to get educated.
And then we're going to try Supermarket Simulator.
It seems like a small two hour game.
I'm going to watch Azura play it
because I don't know what the game is about.
I've never played it,
but I've seen a lot of Etubers play it.
If it's not short,
it might get substituted for this like road
game where you have to try and get the car
to go as long as possible.
But,
you're like,
Strongly Restrictions Disabled Image Preview,
so it's a surprise.
Yes, sir.
Okay.
It might be the long drive.
Yeah, I don't know if Supermarket Simulator
can kind of infinitely go on,
and I need to wrap it up.
I've got Ring Fit Adventure
with my heart rate monitor.
My heart rate monitor is here.
So I wanted to give it a shot.
See how I do in my fitness levels.
Probably shite, let's be honest.
And then we're playing
If that's how you guys want me to pronounce it.
Oh, Supermarket Sim can be easy endurance.
A lot of clapping in that stream.
I mean, if you want it to be, yes.
Oh, it's an infinite game, Supermarket Simulator.
You won't overdo it on this time on Ring Fit.
No, it's like two hours and done,
maybe even an hour and done.
Like, I don't want to be too loud for my dad.
He really does not feel well right now.
After stream, I'm going to check on him,
and I think I'm making him food.
I don't know if I'm about to do the old chicken soup.
Chicken noodle soup for him, I don't know.
But we're playing Ring Fit for two hours,
and then the next thing we're playing,
I'm not going to say it right, ever.
It says,
for two hours,
and then I'm going to go offline for a little bit,
and then at Azura's usual stream time,
me and Azura are going to play We Were Here.
It's like a free puzzle game,
so I'll be curious to see if we can get through it or not.
I have played it once before,
but I don't really remember too much of the details.
Wow, thank you for becoming a member.
Like, Lux, you get me educated, get me educated,
get me educated, blah blah blah.
Yeah.
The goats.
Suica.
Then the stream snipe game is Mario Kart 8.
Now, before you're like,
oh, I can't wait to ruin you in the video game.
I promise you, I have absolutely nothing to offer in the video game.
You will win.
I will be pleading with you to wait at the finish line.
Fiendish, thank you for the extended membership.
Mummy up...
Mummy Square 2? Up 2?
Mummy Up 2.
What does that mean, Mummy Up 2? What are you up to?
But Mario Kart is a stream game,
and I picked it on a weekend.
I was very dumb and didn't pick a weekend
for the Jelly Bean game,
but we do it on weekends.
Mario Kart's subspace game, then no!
Stop the press!
Oh, God, we got a score.
The Sunday Driver, honestly.
My dad's asking me.
He's like, are you going to learn to drive?
I'm like, no, I like my bike.
And then a game that was recommended to me by you,
The Reeflings, is What Remains of Edith Finch.
Apparently, it's like,
super-sure two-hour game type thing.
So everything is planned for two hours this week,
except for the We Were Here collab,
because that's like a go-off,
and then a comeback on again.
Didn't Amy play that?
I couldn't tell you if she played Edith Finch.
I'm not sure.
Okay, let me get rid of the schedule.
And then let me do the next puzzle.
What do I make you do?
Would you rather Strony and Mercy, AC or Amy,
or, wait, sorry, Strony and Mercy,
or AC and me, or Azur and Sheeby.
What would you prefer for this forbidden artwork
that has never seen the late a day?
Strony and Mercy, okay.
I can't believe it.
Okay, Strony and Mercy.
I'll do 450 pieces, I think.
I think this is what I was supposed to do.
Now, I have hidden the artwork.
So before you're like,
oh, I don't know what it is.
You ain't supposed to.
You're not supposed to know what the artwork is.
So it's an actual challenge.
And I thought you were going to be a challenge.
Good luck.
So there isn't a background,
so I had to add a green and purple hue into the background
to make it even more challenging for you.
Now, I don't think any of these artworks were posted.
As far as I'm aware, they've not been posted.
For one reason or another,
we'll not go around to it.
It's not really been a moment to annoy each other with it.
I must go stay strong for the plot-plot-plot roofling.
Oh, thank you for hanging.
Please don't worry.
Is there an option for two pieces only?
A wee bit of a cheat sheet at all.
Take the edge pieces to the respective edges.
Oh, we've got the tactics coming in.
There is no way.
You already have a corner of green.
That's insane.
I think they've already figured out that I'm on the left side.
I don't know. I'm getting the indication the rooflings have figured out
I'm on the left side. I repeat.
I'm a professional edging. Don't worry.
Oh yeah, it's edging time.
Well, you post the artwork there.
Of course, I'll maybe get Mercy to post it
so she can get the Twitter interactions for it.
Because I'm not fussed for Twitter.
Honestly, on Twitter, I'm like,
I'm making prego ASMR. Here's the picture.
And then like, oh my god, thank you for 10,000 subscribers.
We got in a debut highlight
from a previously established clip channel.
And oh my god, everyone's blown ahead in subscribers.
I actually do have good news about anyone who does clipping
and has an established channel.
We, on August 1st, the Allure
are going to...
the Allure.
Alluring.
Are going to release a clipping program
where you get paid for posting clips
if it, you know, like $1 per 1000 views type thing.
Oh my god, why is it so tiny?
Hold on.
Is that the bottom of it already?
Well, you can kind of see Mercy and me coming together, huh?
It was such a well put together cut.
Did you see it?
It literally propelled us ahead so much.
And I'm so thankful.
So I'm very ha...
Oh my god, the puzzle's tiny compared to how many pieces are on the damn thing.
Hmm.
Maybe I've made this too easy?
I mean, you can see me here.
Excuse me, you're doing what together?
I don't know, you're going to have to do the puzzle.
You're going to have to do the puzzle to figure out what we're doing.
But yes, thank you for $10,000.
I'm very excited to see how the ASMR stream's going to go.
I feel like I'm going to, like, rub the bathtub
and everyone's going to be like,
oh, my ears!
And I'll be like, yep, that's kind of what happens when you're in a bathtub.
Could you imagine it's an alternative puzzle?
As much as I would adore to do that?
No.
Oh, look at me!
Hi, me.
Oh, you can see one of my side details and stuff.
Oh, there's my abdomen.
I can see Mercy's belt here.
This is like Mercy's belt.
Oh, my God, Mercy has a belt, yes.
I know you're normally looking at her bowl area.
Oh, look, see, this is Mercy's collar here.
They do such a casual thing.
They are holding hands!
I showed that video with the clips on my friends
and he subscribed all together.
Literally, when we finished the AC collab,
she hit 6,000 subscribers.
And I think, like, she's blown past that.
I mean, I celebrated 10k.
It says I'm at 10.7.
I'm like, oh, my God, the ASMR debt increases.
I'm like, hmm.
I think the scoring might be skewed
because the points are going to the slotted thingy.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, see, Mercy's...
Oh, I apologize for y'all, I'm high.
I got five hours of sleep today,
but I'm going back to...
I'm going back to bed.
Oh, no, I've got the Yumi watch along.
Yumi plus have a concert today.
I could maybe get a nap before it.
I mean, what happens if I had a nap on you, Refland?
You're just so hot and warm to lie on.
And then you pet my hair and I fall asleep
and then you can violently wake me up
for the Yumi plus concert watch along.
I think that would do quite...
Oh, what are me and...
Oh, what's going on?
Me and Mercy, what's going on here?
Hmm.
There's a finger being pointed at Mercy.
Wait a minute, there's a finger being pointed at me.
What is this artwork all about?
A concert of what?
Is it heavy metal?
I don't think they've done heavy metal.
I don't know what they've done.
But...
That's a cosy tube.
Is cosy tube fucking stream sniping right now?
Is someone ERPing is cosy tube?
Be honest right now.
What?
Key signal.
Thank you for the 50 gifted memberships.
What the heck?
Are you serious?
We're playing a puzzle game.
Thank you for the 50 bomb.
Holy moly!
What?
Thank you.
Congrats to those who caught it with your face.
Thank you for the 50 bomb.
Big massive balls doesn't say anything.
Key signal, absolute Chad.
Thank you.
Congrats to those who got it.
Have you seen the Shibi stream?
I saw the start where they read the first script
to say that the script master got an absolute bollocking
as an understatement.
Yeah, he got an absolute bollocking.
Don't get me wrong, it was funny and it made good, hilarious clips.
But I paid, you know, substantial money.
I don't, yeah, so don't worry, don't worry.
Glorps your giggles.
No, don't start it off again.
I don't even want to know.
I listened to Emi and Shibi do it, like,
and then it's the thing.
Oh, Stronys chair.
That was so good.
Mummy's left ball.
I don't.
Stronys gaggle stick.
Are you serious?
I just read that.
No.
Oh my God.
Congrats on everyone who's catching the membership, by the way.
You have emotes.
The more emotes are coming.
I repeat, more emotes are coming.
Shibi, I had to go on her account and Shibi has, like,
20 missing emotes slots right now.
She's got so many emotes she can commission.
Hi.
Thank you for joining.
We're playing a puzzle game.
If you click the link below, not only do I get your IP address
so I can come to your house late at night
when I need to take my frustrations out on you
after losing Valtro,
but you guys have done it.
What do your elf eyes see, little reeflings?
Real.
No.
Okay, you may just get access to the puzzle game.
Oh, sorry.
Wait a minute.
Why are me and Mercy fighting?
Do you want to know why we're fighting?
Because I want to kill you because I'm a siren
and she wants to kill you because she's a yandere
and we're both fighting over who gets to kill you.
That's why I commissioned this artwork.
Because we're fighting over who gets to kill you.
I'm not even kidding.
That's the context of why I commissioned this.
I'm like, no, I want to drown him.
And she's like, no, I'm a yandere.
I have the right to perish him.
Oh, my God.
So that is that one.
Did you like it?
It's us together.
This was very early access.
Before we had nail polish and bandaid designs and such.
But yeah, no, no, no, it's true.
That's true.
Very kawaii ne.
Reconnecting.
Okay.
Next one.
You're not allowed.
No peeking.
Right.
You can have AC and Emmy or you can have Azura and Chibi.
What's your choice, darlings?
Do not giggle sticker puzzle thing.
Honestly.
Kawaii Disney or something.
Yes, exactly.
Kawaii Disney.
Thank you again for the 50 gifted memberships.
That was an incredibly kind key signal.
You absolute Chad comes in, gives memberships, doesn't say a thing, walks away.
You want to do who...
Oh, you guys are actually split.
Oh, but I've got Azura.
Okay, okay, okay.
No.
You guys are going to like this one.
I'll do 450 because I don't want to...
I don't want to take up all your room, you know,
blaze it and all that jazz.
I don't want to take up too much of your time.
Because we've actually...
It's already been an hour and we've done two puzzles.
Wait.
Have we only done two puzzles?
Are you squidding me right now?
Bubba the Great, thank you for the extended membership.
We survived the first month.
Let's go.
Yay.
Thank you.
Okay, new puzzle, puzzle time.
Boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
I want to double boom.
And you come.
So this is a sheebie and Azura artwork together.
The preview has been disabled.
So please have fun with what happens next.
Oh my God, look at you go...
Oh my God.
Actually, can I say something really weird?
I really like watching ant videos.
You know those people that have ant videos
and show the colonies going to work
and how well in that they do?
I think it's really fascinating.
And I really enjoy it.
And I'm kind of getting those vibes.
Oh my God, you guys are doing really well.
I wanted for my doughnathon to maybe have an ant habitarium.
But I don't think I can do it.
Let's start edging, bros.
Ant eater girl for Gen 2.
Well, tomorrow is when I do all my goofy Gen 2 streams, okay?
If you guys want to continue to do puzzles
after my planned ones are done,
I can do the thumbnails if you want.
They're not the most exciting thumbnails.
Can't win them all.
Also, hey, I just got here.
Hi, hi.
Don't worry, don't worry.
We're just ants.
No, reflings, that's not what I meant.
I mean, just look how efficient you are.
This is actually really pleasing to my brain to watch.
Literally, they're so well coordinated.
It's proof that you share a brain.
Oh, we've got Azura in Shibi's face.
I was going to say, I'm going to give you a hint.
Azura is on the, I've colored, the background is colored
to what their color is.
So yeah, Shibi's on the red and Azura's on the purple.
Purples.
I like the taffy sounds a lot.
I have to go for now, but I'll try and come back later for now.
Bye bye.
Thank you for hanging.
Please don't worry.
I can't believe she hates us and wants to be a parent.
Oh, it's my lore.
You forgot my lore.
I want to end all of humanity via hypnosis.
No, that's me who has yet to freaking upload a serious hypnosis video, bruh.
I need to do it.
I'm not beating the accusations of how rubbish a hypnosis is,
but I said, like, when my dad goes home,
I am going to be glued to that recording booth.
I'm not even kidding.
I have so much to catch up on.
I have so many...
Sorry, I'm just putting this back to the start.
I have so many ASMR collabs to finalize
because I do not want to accept any more.
Oh, it's coming together.
But what is Azura and Shibi doing?
What are they doing in this picture?
I just remembered the hypnosis in the bagpipe short, honestly.
We're going to be under a spell.
It's inevitable.
They're hugging something.
What are they hugging?
They're going to figure it out.
Who knows?
The reeflings are working hard and diligently.
Well, I just realized how awkward it is to do Shibi's hair in a puzzle
because it's just like the wippy lanes.
The look they're giving me making my jiggle song.
Shibi, you're done.
I'm not reading any more of that.
Whoopsies.
I mean, you guys are getting there.
I think you're going to be able to figure out what happens next.
You're getting close.
Now, to give you a help in the background,
the Veiler logo is in the background.
Just to give you a helping hand.
So there's a text in the background that says Veiler,
just to make it a bit easier.
It is, yes, copyright free Zelda music.
How dare you identify my peaceful.
My peaceful.
Oh, it's stalled.
I don't know why.
Oh, there we go.
That was strange.
I don't know why that broke.
Okay, it's back.
I'm sorry.
Your peaceful music is back.
I apologize.
She thinks she still needs to spell it and chance me.
Oh.
Is it supposed to be us?
I don't know.
I don't have to come on in and help the puzzle.
I see a lot of blue for his hair.
Yes.
When feet.
I didn't have a feet picture in mind.
I was going to show a heavily censored artwork I got on myself,
but it was pretty outrageous.
I have to admit.
There's three brief ones were jumping me.
Let's just say that's what the artwork was.
They were jumping me.
Both their hair is a puzzle on their own.
Honestly.
So when are you going to release puzzles?
Oh, you went like an actual physical puzzle.
Honestly, a micro puzzle would be adorable.
I don't care what anyone says.
I think a micro puzzle would be adorable.
Jumping you affectionately.
Yes.
Very affectionately.
Very, very, very engaging, if you will.
A word by that marriage.
I think it would be cute.
Maybe I can order custom puzzles and be like, hey, I have like 100.
I mean, you guys are getting there.
You're getting very close.
Now, a remainder that Azura has weight on her ears.
She has gooped ears.
So maybe that's a bit of a hinge.
As always, Madame has her lovely suit.
Throughout Heaven and Earth, we are the jumping ones.
The reeflings are me, myself and I.
I cannot wait to write that pregnancy script.
It's going to be the most wild thing.
And before I get so passionate about it,
it's like a one hour long like sleep aid audio,
but like I talk for the first 30 minutes.
And then like we have a nap together whilst you're in my tummy.
I can just see me getting so passionate when I write about it.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm so happy I get to fucking make pregnant with you ASMR.
Like, ah, this is exactly what I want to do.
I don't want to be serious.
I don't want to be trihard.
Double heartbeat ASMR.
Boom, boom.
A bit too affectionate maybe.
Hydration check reeflings.
I'm having to drink water.
No tea.
I'm having no tea today because I need to...
Oh!
Oh, reeflings.
What do you see?
We're getting edged with the last piece.
Any Azura and Shibi fans?
Is that you?
Be honest, reeflings.
Is that you in the middle and enjoying the embrace?
The big embraces?
Yeah?
Yeah, you enjoying the embrace?
I'm glad.
That's me.
Hmm.
Where's Azura's hand reaching to?
You don't worry about that part.
Okay, that part comes later.
I'm being hugged by the wrong woman.
The outline makes me think it's throwing me.
Hmm.
Four big personalities collide.
Being spoiled by Madam and Mama is the best.
Yeah.
Okay, now last but certainly not least.
Once this expired is a Emmy and AC together.
Being so adorable.
Let me just hide my screen so you guys don't get any spoilers to what's ahead.
But here is AC and Emmons.
Again, we'll just do 450 please.
Because it's a good...
Or I think it's a good number.
It's not too difficult.
It didn't take too long.
And the room can be found.
Pe-A-Z-Z-L-A.
Ta-da!
Now this is a Emmy and AC.
So orange and blue.
Yeah.
Let's get...
On your marks.
Get set.
Spoiler, there's a screen.
I must unfortunately decline the offer of that embrace.
You can be hugged by any member of your luring.
Cheeky young.
Okay, I think I might be really cheeky and after the stream go for a nap before the Yumi Plus stream.
Is that bad of me?
Is that naughty?
I think it is naughty.
I'm a sleepy baby.
I got five hours.
Orange and blue.
Florida colours.
No, movie poster colours.
Remember that post that broke down that all movie posters are blue and orange hue?
It's only not if you don't wake up in time.
We gotta quickly fin...
We gotta finish quickly to get her rims.
Oh no, don't worry about it like that.
It's not like that.
Oh, I see Emmy.
Emmy's being made.
But where's AC's face?
I don't see AC.
Oh, there she is.
She's starting to form over here.
You guys are doing it.
Okay, we've got a border on AC's side.
It's coming over.
I'm just gonna plop it down there, but Emmy is thoroughly...
Well, I can see AC's cold in here.
Is that AC's belt, maybe?
Oh, I see Emmy's belt.
See, Emmy has a belt like this.
This is the wee piece here.
Oh god, I misunderstood me.
Said Emmy's being made.
No, I have to...
That's an ASMR booth.
No, in theory, the girls were conceptualised...
with us all together.
No, you'll be full of energy.
So you can cheer as loud and proud for Yume Plus, honestly.
I'm so excited to see there.
Me asking them for notes like, hey, how did you do this?
By the way, not asking for no particular reason.
Like, hey, what did it cost?
How did you do it?
I just need to know so I can do it for my girls.
That'd be great if you can give me some insider knowledge.
I'd appreciate it.
Okay, what's going on?
Emmy, Emmy's coming together.
I see Emmy's tummy.
And she's got her hands together.
I know what's happening here, but I can see...
Oh, look at the smugness on AC.
What's going on here?
Veiler concert win?
I don't know, it depends.
But look at the...
Emmy's brought to tears.
Why would my daughter...
Why would my darling daughter be brought to tears?
What is going on in this image?
Emmy with brown hair?
No, she's ginger, I promise you.
She's ginger.
I was so confused why she thought she was blonde.
I'm like, in what universe, my damn?
You are not blonde, my dearest.
AC stealing her big bro?
No.
But you're putting the image together.
I think you'll be able to tell shortly.
What do you mean again, AC's big bro?
Emmy fake cries all the time, I'm not filled.
She's probably on his pack.
She still insists she's dirty blonde.
She's ginger.
If she wants to say she's dirty blonde, I'm not arguing.
As long as she's happy, I'm happy.
But the concept is that she's a ginger.
She's in denial, that's what she is.
Someone just guessed it.
AC being taller.
So if you didn't know,
Emmy is 140 centimetres.
But AC is 142 centimetres.
So what is this artwork portraying?
Hi, Elf.
Elf Jeff, what kind of profile picture is that?
Is that Doctor House is like a telly tubby?
What is your profile picture?
Elf Jeff, thank you for becoming a member.
But oh my god, is that Doctor House
is a telly tubby?
Yeah, oh my god, that was off.
Emmy Burley, no.
Emmy's not the Burley in this one.
This is very...
Thank you for becoming a member, I do appreciate that though.
Thank you for the support.
Hugh, Larry as Tinky Winky.
House, I get.
But I don't see the telly tubby.
That means they don't look...
Do not look like Tinky Winky nor Dipsy.
What if it's AC with heels?
I don't know, I think AC is taller.
What's this?
I was gonna say, I recognise this.
Right, this is AC's tummy, I can tell.
Oh sorry, sorry, sorry, I didn't mean to.
Oh no, no, no, no, the meds, not the meds, not the meds.
Don't get digested yet.
Slow release capsules, slow release capsules.
Do not digest the meds, okay?
Do not digest the meds.
Old hair colour.
She was sponding as a junior.
My ex would say 2cm mirrors isn't that much.
Do we laugh?
Or is this kind of like a therapy confession?
Wait, what do we do in response to that refling?
Hello Bobbi, I apologise.
No, no, don't apologise for being late, don't worry.
Point and empathise.
Oh boy.
We pour one out for the whole year.
No, don't worry about being late, we're literally just like giffing off doing some puzzles.
Point and cry.
Head pat the refling, head pat, pat, pat, pat, pat, pat.
Okay, we're putting AC together, we've managed to do ME,
but I guess because AC's face is sideways, you guys are struggling a wee bit.
Oh is someone trolling?
Hold on, I think someone's trolling.
One second.
Oh, that's not very nice.
Here we go.
Ta-da!
Ooh, pat, pat, pat, pat, put AC together.
Pat, pat, pat, pat, put other pieces together.
That is terrible.
Tiny, spiny, that is terrible.
Thank you for the tip.
No, we're not doing that.
Oh, okay, I'll put the last one on myself then.
I think everyone disconnected, so technically I put the last piece on myself.
Ta-da! Look!
So this artwork, now this was before I had the girls.
Again, this was before I knew who the girls were and how they're enjoying themselves.
But AC is two centimeters taller than me.
And AC has very wide hips and thigh ratio, whereas Emmy's quite plank-like.
But I don't mean that as an insult, I mean like true to Patan.
Like she's not very curvy, whereas AC is rather curvy.
And she does have a little bit of something.
Ta-da!
Very important detail for future collaboration.
The two little babies arguing over who's taller, even though they're both totally, honestly.
It gave me one moment.
Right, what have I got next?
Right, this one's going to be a super fast one because it's not the most exciting.
This originally was going to be an artwork used for an ASMR video, but I can't use it because...
Because ASMR on YouTube is rather odd at the moment.
I'm not really sure.
Um...
Wait, hold on, let me pin it.
Okay, there we go.
Patreon won't lay- oh no, Patreon will, but um...
Yes, good luck with the artwork.
Now the artwork, I will give you a hint, is very awkward for the background.
Because the background is a spiral.
So I've made this 240 pieces, so I've made it a lot less.
Image of lungs breathing?
Yeah, breathing, basically.
You'll see it once you put it together.
Oh, you've already got my face, hold on.
No way, you're that fast.
You've never even seen the image before.
How are you so fast?
Hello, it's me Anonymous.
Hmm.
How are you so fast at making it?
There's a 3D art.
No way, you guys are that fast.
As high as the background is really difficult because it's like...
Everything's no mummy.
Oh, mummy's looking at the video.
No, you can't prove it, no.
There's no proof.
There's only proof once you've finished the image.
That Anon me, everyone in this lobby is me, I am Anon.
Wait, hold on, let me get out of the way, I'm in the way.
It's strong in time, I love strong calls.
Hello, it's me Anonymous, there's the 3D art.
Anon me, everyone in this lobby is me, mummy.
Your tongue is...
I can do it twice.
I made this pose.
Hypnotizing as if you're licking.
I don't know, you're gonna have to find out, you're just gonna have to do the puzzle.
Anon, we are replaying.
I'm gonna see if I can lurk here so you can still see the in-game chat if you wanted to.
You're licking us.
This.
Okay.
I never got a custom 3D or asset.
I'm not really that fuss for like custom assets.
I hope the girls aren't disappointed with me because I never really did that.
Like some feature agencies like, oh here's a custom, like game and set up, custom microphone, custom...
Like, nail asset and I'm just like, I can't really be arsed with that.
If the girls want it, they can get it in their donor thoughts.
Which sounds terrible, but I'm like, I've never been fussed for it.
It's terrible, I really shouldn't do it that way, but...
If I'm no fussed for it, the girls then they get it.
What's this?
Oh, you cut my hair together.
I don't know how I did that on the first go, but I did it.
So this is called a jigsaw, yeah.
And you can join in and have fun.
We'd let you hypnotise us and destroy humanity.
Yeah, I don't know if maybe my hearts have been softened by the reeflings
and I have been redeemed, if you will.
And that I no longer wish to perish humanity.
I'm starting to think that I definitely am having a change of heart to my lore.
So the reeflings have changed me for the better.
Their tentacles made all the difference and now I don't want to kill everyone anymore.
All thanks to your tentacle reefling.
Yeah, I don't want to perish humanity anymore.
Maybe just hold us like cow.
Right, now this is where this gets really awkward because there's so many hues.
So many hues and my hair really doesn't help either.
My hair makes this so awkward.
Pen up frustrations and wanting the world to end a timeless combo.
Stop, I will make that canon.
Stop, that's such a good lore edit.
Thank you tiny spiny.
I don't know how you guys feel about that, but maybe the reeflings softened my hearts
and I realised the problem wasn't humanity.
The problem was the high table.
I am so down.
And instead of using my hypnosis to take them down,
I hypnotise you to take them down for me.
I would abs strongly wick.
Honestly, down with that, yes, update your lore.
I just got timed out.
I think, I don't know if it's like breaking a bit.
Not all of humanity, just a handful of people.
Yeah, you use us.
Well, after you've taken down the high table,
I have all the time in the world to our word yet.
Oh my lord, it's like a dosion where the hero smashes the villainess into not being evil anymore.
Yeah, basically, I will commission that.
Please do not think I will commission that.
Maybe I could get like a proper dosion spread.
I don't know how much they cost though.
So one shot dosions I think can run like, depending on how many panels you have,
shy of a thousand, but like a full on spread.
I don't even know where you'd commission that honestly.
Did I see that?
Is it moving your positions?
Is it actually telling me who's picking up and dropping out?
Okay.
Is it our word?
If we like it, who knows?
We don't know yet.
I know an artist who does 50 per page with four panels a page.
Yes, I think when it comes to Donothon.
So, oh, I can't say that yet.
I can say it tomorrow.
I think I could say it tomorrow.
Right, I can't say it just yet, but I'll say it tomorrow.
A screenshot when someone keeps moving it.
Oh my God, what is that?
This is giving me a stroke and not a good count.
That's me.
That's my thing.
I think it's lagging out, unfortunately.
How do you even move the puzzle?
It's not moving.
Let me just fix over here.
I'll take the high score off because I don't even see the score.
The mods turned that wifling into Tokoyaki.
I came back to Crazy Talk.
It's not Crazy Talk if it's my lore, okay?
I'm allowed to have lore.
No, that doesn't sit there.
Oh, I dropped my piece.
Oops.
Oh.
Yeah, we're lagging a little bit.
Mods, deep fry that wifling.
We're breaking the site.
It's taming out.
It's the site taming out.
Oh, something about our wording.
It was a mis-
It was a mis-input.
We're breaking the website stop.
That's actually so funny.
I feel so bad, though.
I'm sorry, Mr. Website owners.
We're just having fun making puzzles.
That's all.
They're going to be like,
who on earth is this weirdo licking the mic?
Because they can see the images as it's getting made.
They'll be like, what is going on here?
So, originally, this artwork was going to be a subscriber milestone,
but all of them are going to have to go on Twitter instead for free
because YouTube is stinky and it sucks.
Hello, I'm back.
Oh, my.
Yeah, look.
So, I was originally going to use it,
and the artist was really good
because I was like,
oh, can you just like make-
can you do something with a microphone
just so it's a bit more unique than a default?
Don't hold it.
So, it was going to go on YouTube,
but it failed because YouTube is stinky.
But that's my artwork, and it's me.
And I'm so cute.
And then I asked for like some custom stuff on it,
and they just like put me sticker on it.
I'm like, yeah, I'll take it.
I don't think I had your model yet.
I don't think I had your model yet,
but if I do get a custom 3DO asset,
I'm going to get you on it,
and I'll be like,
I'll get a little sticker here,
and then a little speech,
and it says, I was R-worded,
and you're all happy about it.
There's something like that.
I don't know what.
And then that's me with my little squiggly,
wiggly eye.
I like the way it does.
Okay.
Now I do have...
Hold on, I'm from my dad's birth.
I'm so weird.
Okay, let me hide it,
and then we'll make a new puzzle, okay?
It's so cute.
Thank you.
Okay, what's the image?
Okay, you have a choice of a meme or a comic strip.
Both involve all the girls.
Meme?
Or comic strip?
Your choice.
Dayler's choice.
Comic strip, meme, comic, meme, meme, meme.
Oh, meme one.
Okay, meme one.
Meme one.
Hold on.
I am going to do 450 pieces for this one,
because it's got all of us in it, okay?
So don't be shy.
Do some more.
Let's see.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
Generating puzzle.
You ready?
I know it looks confusing.
Hold on, I'm putting the puzzle in chat right now.
Puzzle.
This one slightly more difficult,
but have a show?
Have a show?
Have a goal?
I like that idea of being hypnotized is me to feel it.
Good luck with this one.
This is not an easy one.
My fingers is hard.
I love Johnny Cuddles.
I love Reefling.
Are you Reefling Cuddles?
Is that your full legal name?
Reefling Cuddles?
Yeah, Reefling Cuddles would be your full name.
Yeah.
By the Pope.
Now remember, this is a meme.
This is not an easy one.
Oh, some's already got the bottom corner credit for the artist.
We'll take on your last name if you want us to.
Yeah.
Are we taking your last name?
Reefling Cuddles?
Pipe Jim, we could get a comic for the girls.
That would be rad.
Yeah, of course.
I would never say no to that.
If the girls want comics, I'll make them.
Someone out there is going to get a legal name change to Reefling Cuddles now.
That would be pretty badass, sorry,
but they would get my used panties in the mail or something,
because that's so badass.
No, do not actually legalize me for your name.
We'd be taking your last name.
We have no full name.
We have the title, though.
Reefling the Ink Supplier!
Reefling the Plentiful,
Reefling the Bountiful,
Reefling the Unending Ink...
Ink...
Reveal her dosion.
Let's go.
I would never say no to that.
Never say no.
Making a fake person a name in a mania?
It's too late.
I've set it in stone.
You've already contacted...
Oh!
I see Azura forming.
I see Emmy.
I see I see I see Azura on me.
Sorry, I'm punching the mic right now.
My apologies.
Oh, the bottom.
The bottom is starting to show hints.
Emmy.
I will very quickly move over
just so you can see the bottom is showing hints
of what this content is.
Punch again.
I'm not punching the mic.
Fade the mic.
Boom, boom, boom.
Resisting the urge to change the name change.
The name change...
No!
Elden Ring Boss Drop.
Reefling the Bountiful.
All the Vela girls have their own pills.
Nice.
Oh!
But wait, there's more.
There's more to this meme.
Oh.
Oh wait, why does it...
Well, I got bigger.
Yeah.
Again there.
Oh, what's this?
Oh!
Reeflings cracked the case on Azura.
I repeat, the Reeflings have cracked the case on Azura.
What is this artwork all about?
Oh!
Reeflings are doing it.
They're doing it.
They're cracking the case wide open.
What is this meme all about?
So is it for Gotham?
Alright, we got Azura packing up.
Rep it up.
Stream idea for fstreams?
Literally this, except...
Yeah, no, I'd be done for that, that's hilarious.
Oh my god, we should do a puzzle on Bansley.
And then we have to all squeeze one out to it.
And then we wait 15 minutes and then we have to go next!
I'd be so down for that, that's hilarious.
Would you change your legal name for a Reefling snack?
I have to do it?
We have to like force ourselves?
By the third one all of us are like, we can't go on.
Go on without us.
There'll be one Reefling that's like, you guys are struggling?
Different kind of endurance stream.
Oh, the case is getting cracked wide open.
Oh wow, completely just sealed off the lower section of this meme.
I'm loving this, I'm so sorry if it's like low entertainment.
I am adoring this, like revealing artwork via making you do logic puzzles.
It is hilarious, I'm sorry, but it is.
Like, you will be rewarded with new artwork that you haven't seen before,
but first you must do this puzzle.
That's absolutely ridiculous.
Guys, can you solve a little sorority of rest, honestly?
It's like why old wizard riddles?
Astority, this one needs to be poster wall art.
Oh my god.
No.
Which one of these pills is piagra?
Stop!
Why do they ask for which one?
I think piagra's blue.
Surely.
I mean, you guys have done so well, that was not an easy one.
You guys keep doing so well, I can't believe it.
This is peak iPad entertainment.
Stop is actually.
I'm taking the strony fell.
Yes, so this meme concept.
So I ordered artwork of everyone stepping on the viewer.
Now, this was before Azura was finalized with her reference sheet.
Azura is a lot more chocolate in her concept art, and this is what the artist had to use.
And she's a lot, and she's not even got her markings and stuff.
You know, this is older.
But yeah.
And you can tell this one's older for me, because I have brown, like, apparel things that come out the back.
That's when you know it's not my design.
Again, Shibi has lines instead of ropes, the classic.
Mercy, no nail polish.
No one has nail polish at this stage of development when I ordered this,
but I was like, yeah, I want to step on new artwork.
I'm so red-pilled.
Skinny Azura jumpscare.
I cannot tell you how many times I have to go to an artist and be like,
make her plump.
She's a mummy.
Literally, she has birthed all of humanity.
She got them birth in hips.
She got a tummy.
You know?
What are you doing?
AC censored me live in a society.
It was very, there we go.
You did it.
You unlocked the meme.
Check it out.
Steps on you.
Okay, I believe I have one more artwork.
But yeah, it was like, pick your pill.
The purple, the green, the red, the purple.
Oh, we didn't think that.
Wait, what?
The light purple, the lilac, I guess.
And then the purple, the orange, or the blue.
Purple and purple.
Hmm.
Yes.
Maybe we should have done pink,
because Mercy does have a bit of pink in her design.
That probably would have been wiser, but hey-ho.
Pink, but yeah, I would say pink as well.
I'll take all six.
Are you going to half them all?
An ironically great advertisement?
Oh, really?
You like that?
Wait, I'll get this changed to pink,
and then we'll put it on the main viewer, kind of, or that.
And we're done.
Wait, hold on.
Let me just double check my files.
Oh, no, there's...
Okay, there's an ASMR collab artwork with all of us together.
It could have made you pink in her teal.
Yes.
Hi, Fua.
There's an ASMR collab artwork,
or there is a meme comic strip.
ASMR or meme comic strip.
I didn't see the other image that I had lurking in the shadows.
Hi.
We need to see the art collab.
ASMR, ASMR.
Meme, comic, comic, comic, ASMR.
Oh, you guys are like 50-50 split, ASMR.
All right, we'll do the ASMR,
but I'll do 250 pieces.
250 blazes.
Great.
This one has the Veiler logo in the background,
just for simplicity's sake,
because again, it's one of those ones where it's rather on the odd side.
Puzzle.
Oh, I like this game where you put it in your own image.
Yes.
I highly recommend it for streams.
I'm currently leaking artwork that's never been seen before via puzzles.
I'm making them do logic puzzles in order to access it.
It's the most bizarre thing Fua.
So you should consider it.
Rustic, thank you for the gen...
Try again.
Thank you, Rustic, for the gentifted mentorship.
What?
Hello, Rustic.
Thank you so much for the gifted 10 memberships to the channel.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
And congrats to those who caught it with your face.
What was that?
I'm taking a drink of water right now.
Oh my gosh.
I'm taking water.
I need to...
I think I'm having a nap after this one.
Thank you for the gifted memberships.
Oh my god.
I think I need a good sleep.
But I'm okay.
I could not get that out there.
Gentifted memberfish?
That's not what I said.
Nice.
It's only just having a stroke.
I'm thinking about the bands these streams a little too much.
But yes, Fua, I highly recommend leaking artwork
via making puzzle streams.
It's absolutely hilarious.
Because I'm showing stuff that's not been shown yet.
And it's just so fun.
Oh, we already have our canvas.
Now, it did make it a wee bit easier.
I didn't do too much.
Oh yeah?
Okay, I'm having the time of her life.
The gentifted member.
How did you jumble those words in perfect sequence?
I do it quite often.
I can accidentally swat.
I take the first letter.
Oh god, I'm supposed to say that.
Knee die, Julie.
Thank you for the 20 gifted memberships.
That's right.
I said it right this time.
What are you going to do about it, huh?
Are you disappointed?
Knee die, Julie.
That I said it correctly.
20 gifted memberships.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate that.
You guys are going to end up getting me another emoji slot.
You know that, right?
I'm like, people are so fast.
I'm trying to get a single piece.
That reflins are on it like a blood type.
I did pick out 250 pieces for this one
because I didn't know.
Strongly struggling.
Strongly is struggling.
But congrats to those who caught it with their face.
And you have access to all the emotes.
There's more emotes on the way.
I promise.
I have 13 more emotes.
And give Mercy some room.
Please excuse me.
Mommy, the reflins are hogging the shared brain cell.
Oh, it's okay.
Sleepy Phoenix.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tip.
But yes.
I don't know what happened there.
I took a drink of water
and now I can speak all over again.
So that's good.
That's good.
We should make a thousand.
It only goes up to 700, I think.
So this is the next group.
ASMR collab.
What do you think it is, reflins?
What do you think is happening in this collab?
I got one!
Yippee!
Are you squidding me right now?
Wait, that is so delayed.
That is so delayed.
Thank you again, Sleepy Phoenix.
Are you okay, YouTube?
You took a sec.
I read that quite a moment before.
Do 1,000 rotated pieces
blowing air into our ears?
Not air.
Not blowing.
A different kind of ASMR.
A group kiss?
We're sniffing you ASMR.
All six of us are sniffing you going
but it's binaural sniffing.
So six binaural layered sniffing
and you're going to be pheromone maxing for us, okay?
So that's what the next group ASMR collab is with us.
It's all about pheromone maxing.
I hope you're ready for it.
The full sniffing experience.
That's 12 nostrils to smell every little piece of you.
No shower for a month, God, at the big sniff.
God, I hope she likes my pheromone stink.
With me, everything will be ready for it.
But yeah, look, are you humping?
Are you? Why are you gyrating the image?
Why are you doing this sexually?
Briefly.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Fucking steady.
I need a bit of fire play.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, there is 1,000 pieces.
Okay, I don't think I'm going to do it on this image.
There's images too difficult to do 1,000 pieces on.
We'll do 450 pieces.
Let's see, 450 blaze it.
Great room.
Comic time.
So originally, I was going to release a monthly comic on Villalour.
Like, for the pro, I'm going to sneeze.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
That was really weird.
Puzzle.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
Sorry, that was a weird one.
Bless you.
Thank you, Bill.
Aggressive sneeze, yeah.
I'm afraid I'm not.
Get out of my nose kind of sneeze.
Okay, now, originally, I was going to do a comic
every month kind of Villalour.
Fun.
Damn, she busted me sneezes.
Apparently, it's one-tenth of it.
Be aggressive on me however you prefer.
Yes, but the plan kind of failed through
because it wasn't going to work out.
I need like a specific artist type for it
and I couldn't get a hold of one.
And then I got so busy with all the other issues.
Like I've kind of said, like debut was,
the month of May was absolutely horrific.
Everyone went past deadlines.
Everyone, like when, even when I was getting sent stuff
that was complete, it was like,
it was like a joke because there was so many obvious edits
and fixes and subtitle issues or whatever
and it was just horrible.
So yeah, this plan got put on the back burner.
I'm not really sure.
I want to do unspeakable things with Strony Cuttles
or do you want me to do unspeakable things to you?
What one is it?
Quick.
The Wheel of King.
What?
There's no way you can see that.
Have I shown this before?
How could you have guessed that?
Amy, is that you on and all?
Is that one of you guys?
How could you have guessed that?
It's been a tough year at Commission Art.
It's not their fault.
I think everyone has taken a lot of work
because things are getting more expensive.
Well, yes.
Some artists unfortunately do over-promise on deadlines.
How could you have fricking guessed that?
I don't know. Zoom in.
We can read Mummy.
Oh, okay.
Yes.
No, there was a lot of developmental issues
with Veilor behind the scenes.
I commissioned stuff well in advance
and then it was announced that Veilor's debut was on June 1
and collectively, I kid you not,
every single artist that we were working with
saw that and then all of a sudden,
my commission that was on track was getting delayed
past the deadline I had given
and it just became an absolute nightmare.
So don't be surprised that Gen 2
don't have an announcement date
until it's actually all ready to go
because I am not going through that stress again.
I literally almost developed a stomach ulcer.
It was that bad.
I like Sheeby's chest has been put together.
Have you put her?
You've put together Sheeby's booba.
But yes, this was just kind of like a test sample
for the comics.
This was a draft, a sample, if you will.
I will give you a hint.
Mercy is talking to me in the first panel at the top.
That is your hint for this puzzle.
Mercy and I are having a conversation.
I'm sorry it was so stressful.
I'm still amazed at the amount of what you did
to prepare for debuting yourself.
Yes!
Everything got put on the back burner for me
to make sure the girls and everything was correct.
Oh, you've already done it.
Holy shit, you've already got a little scared.
Well, there you go.
You got the comic outline.
Ta-da!
Oh, it's gone.
But I worked it in the end.
That's the most important thing.
I am absolutely not telling any artists.
I'm just giving deadlines that are fair.
Anyway, lessons learned.
It was a massive learning curve.
Honestly, anything new you do in life
is a massive learning curve.
So I'm glad that I had the opportunity to do it.
It was a hoot and a holler.
If curiosity, which of the girls can draw,
all of them have some sort of drawing experience but me.
I am the only one that has zero skills.
Literally, my only skill is licking a microphone
and I stand by that proudly.
That's all I got going for me.
That and my addiction to reeflings.
That's what I got going for me.
Life's good.
That's all I need.
Life is good.
All her skill points went to specific games
and her tongue game, honestly.
You're a great entertainer.
Oh, you stop.
Yeah, you're gonna make me blue.
Oh, that's not gonna stop you.
Your voice is hoot too.
My actual voice?
I don't know.
I feel it in my eyes.
That's what I feel like I sound like.
That's what I sound like in my head.
Who said Farky?
Oh, it's in the comic strip.
Sorry, it's in the comic strip.
A master assassin.
I am a master assassin in Assassin's Creed.
The best game of all time, which we get to play
on December...
December, October 10th.
That's your actual voice?
Voice, I can't believe it dropped through.
October 10th, we're playing Assassin's Creed
all over again and I'm so excited.
I'm so excited.
I just can't hide.
And on October 8th, we're playing Assassin's Creed 2
and then the next day, we're doing 100% feather run
and then we're playing Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
on my birthday, which I'm so excited about
when I get two days.
Well, it's gonna be a 40-hour event.
It's crashing again.
Oh my god.
Am I allowed to fart? Excuse me.
Actually, I just want you all to know
that...
Amy...
I'm gonna out her right now.
Amy sent me two clips of her farting
to be highlighted into a short.
I did not go seek them out.
She sent them because she was like,
oh, this is kind of funny.
I had to send a...
a new person that is working with Veal
or two clips of Amy farting.
I'm like, you know, I had to type up a message.
I'm like, hi.
Thank you so much for waiting on your first batch of work.
Here's a link to the clips
that the talent Amy has requested to be made into shorts.
You have full editing rights.
We're not gonna dictate it.
And the last two clips were her farting.
Did they think you were joking?
She took it on stream.
Oh, she took it. She took it twice.
She forced it out.
I had to sit and review the clip
to send away to make sure it was acceptable
to be turned into a short.
So I had to listen to Amy go...
and then a little took came out.
And then she's like, did you hear it?
Did you hear it?
I did it!
Like, she was so proud of herself.
Expelling that air from her guts, honestly.
That editor, happy as Larry.
No, the editor came back and was like,
crass humor like that doesn't normally land.
Amy not beating the allegations.
That's so funny.
She even made a face to...
Where did you even find these girls?
The girls found me!
That's the best part.
I'll be here.
They were crazy enough to be like,
yeah, I want to be a part of that.
And I'm like, oh, don't mind if I do.
So anyway, again, as I said,
this is just a draft concept of a comic strip
that we may or may not do.
That's so funny.
She's giving us a real girlfriend experience.
I feel sorry for the guy,
but I love my little sister that, honestly.
It's a crass noise, alright.
I don't have my...
I don't have my set on board open.
I'm just gonna have to do it myself.
Eh...
Shawnee is a master reefling wrangler?
Oh yeah.
Ooh boo, tomato, tomato.
How about speaking out?
Why am I all too ill all of a sudden?
Oh, that one was a whistle note.
Her LLE came out with me there.
No one noticed yesterday,
Azura's horns and shebe's chest
with the little paper on top
give birth to the seventh...
What?
No one noticed, but yesterday,
Azura's horns and shebe's chest
with the little paper on top
give birth to the seventh secret member of your...
What are you saying?
I don't know what you're saying.
What does that mean?
Now we just need a Shawnee to enclet...
No!
Well, for my doughnut song, yes!
But in general, no!
During the VTuber review collab or something?
Am I going crazy?
The paper above a head?
And there might be ways.
Who is...
You don't need to move the thing anymore,
Reefland.
Or is it just lagging out completely?
It may be lagging out as well, so...
Someone keeps shaking it.
I think it's definitely lagging out
because we've overloaded their wee servers.
The lag makes me feel like...
Ooh, so this is the first comic.
I don't know if it's entertaining enough.
Maybe I'll get it professionally ironed out.
But this was, again, before I knew the girls
and the designs and all that jazz.
American Idol.
Ta-da!
So the comic goes,
So, if Vila doesn't do suspensions,
how do you punish us?
And I say, oh, I just spin the wheel.
The wheel?
If you misbehave,
I commission artwork on whatever lands the wheel lands on.
And it's like all these, like, stuff
that you don't normally do.
And everyone goes,
Well, babe!
Because we don't do suspensions at Vila.
I have absolutely no desire to do it.
I think it's disgusting.
So, yeah, that was my meme on, like,
this is what happened.
This is what I do.
And then that's my face all serious.
That was my first draft of a meme.
I thought it was rather humorous,
but, yeah.
Oh, StrayPube.
Bro, when I figured out what StrayPube was,
I was like, is this for real?
But it's a real tag.
It's funny.
Um, yeah.
Serious?
More like psychotic reaction image of StrayPube.
If you misbehave, Reeflings.
Um, I think that's all the images I had to share.
Now, I could do my thumbnails.
If you want, very quickly,
we could do my thumbnails for the week.
They're not too exciting.
Um, would you like to do that before I go offline, yeah?
That's the one in the corner of the mouth, right?
I hate it.
It depends.
I'm in the corner.
Yes, you want to do my thumbnails.
Okay, one second.
I'm just pulling them up now.
Shimmy, shimmy, yeah, shimmy, yeah, shimmy, yeah.
Drank.
How many thumbnails have I got?
Now, I will make these smaller.
I think I'm actually going to go back on the Mario Kart one before.
Anyone's like, I'm really disappointed in that.
That was my PC.
That wasn't you.
My PC takes like a whole five seconds to comprehend that it's just downloaded an image.
It has such a hissy fit over it.
I'm definitely going to go back in the Mario Kart one and add you guys in it because...
Right.
I'll try.
I'll test what 50 pieces looks like.
I don't know, 50 is like far too easy though.
Okay.
No, I feel like 50 is just...
Fuck it, fuck it.
We'll try 50.
Okay, we'll try 50.
It's not a big deal because we have other ones to go through if we want, if we so desire.
Oh my God, this is far too easy.
No, sorry, this is what I see.
Just so you know, this is what I see.
That's far too easy.
No, we're not doing that.
We'll do 250, believe it.
My apologies.
I thank you guys.
My PC hates putting input.
Oh my God, it hates me.
Just so you know.
Only 50...
The wiefling is drowning.
Everyone does one piece each.
We have to be organized like that.
Okay, these are the last...
There's seven more to go, but these are the last puzzles.
And then we're done!
We did it!
We did all the puzzles.
So you can see a little bit of text.
You can see there's a red stop sign.
Maybe some sort of red stop sign.
I'm glad Mummy did this to me.
She likes to do puzzles for other reasons.
Are you enjoying it?
I'm glad.
I feel like it's so fun doing little insider stuff.
I definitely want to do this in the future
when I get more artworks for the girls and stuff.
Me leaking gen 2 via puzzles!
Stop!
The reason I'm saying stop is because I'm dumb enough
to want to try and do that.
No, I'm not leaking gen 2 designs.
Via a fucking puzzle game.
So this is my first stream tomorrow,
which is
drawing
your gen 2 suggestions.
So what would I put inside the big red sign?
Alright, I'm lurking for the rest.
Kisses!
Thank you for hanging and be playing.
Yes, I will wrap up the stream,
and we will redirect into Shibu!
Cotton bomb!
Sorry, I'm having a big stretch.
But this was so fun.
This was such a little goofy stream.
Bye-bye!
Bye-poo-ah!
Thanks for being chinny,
thanks for hanging.
Alright, I'll zoom in a little bit more.
She hates slime girls.
Yeah, the sign says no slime girls.
But I already know I'm going to have to draw one.
I already know I'm going to have to draw one.
Oh yeah, has anyone said Shibu
said she wants to try a G-mod?
Oh my god, I need to buy the thing.
I need to buy the game for real, for real.
Bye-bye-poo-ah!
Thanks for hanging.
Thanks for completing the puzzle with this as well.
It was fun.
Please do a puzzle stream
and link inside your art of your stuff.
Your content is so fun.
I so recommend it.
Oh yeah, I really want to see the beat of a prop one.
I already,
I hate the feeling of being chased,
and I already know I'm going to be screaming
and excitement being chased,
but if I'm like hating as a prop
and like one of them susses me out,
thank you for always being so nice and comfy to watch.
Oh thank you for, what the heck, that's so kind.
I've returned the compliments to you.
You're always a cozy streamer too.
I saw your post on Twitter
with all your nickel variations and that,
and I was like, damn, you got some,
some alternatives.
You got loads of stuff that you can do, which is fantastic.
Mum is screaming because of us.
No, I'm not screaming.
But the feeling of being chased
gets me like so excited and giddy,
and if one of the girls was chasing me in Gmodor,
they know I'll be like,
like I'll be like burst out laughing
because I get nervous laughter with chasing as well.
I don't know,
there's just something like primal in me
that gets activated.
Sorry, the red hue,
I just realized how awkward the red hue is making this.
There's so much red hue.
Actually, for an ASMR I'm working on,
it's gonna be interesting.
ASMR, you say?
3DO, you say?
Is that a collab on the horizon?
No one will know.
Teasing, teasing.
Mummy, you should look into primal play.
Wait, is that a thing?
Stop, hold on.
Am I about to get educated?
Primal play.
Primal play centers around the raw feeling
and actions and natural impulses,
especially urges.
And while I understand you are the sub in...
What?
Oh, this is like an article.
Some people who do primal play switch roles
and chase them instead.
What the fuck?
Mummy's a primal play girl.
Stop, is that what I am?
I just want something new.
What do you think?
Drawing Gen 2 suggestions.
No slime girls!
No, who said 3DO, that's gonna...
I mean, you know, I could just teach me how to do it professionally.
Oh no!
Alright, I'll hit you up in the DMs boob and grill them
where I got you.
And Neko this.
Neko needs...
Neko needs pamper you to sleep.
Gotta make it rain.
Over like a window.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Viscous liquids girl.
She smells fresh meat.
Article trying to call it.
Literally, I typed in primal prey.
Can I speak here anymore?
Insight girl and goblin girls?
There's a lot of bang girls.
You can ask for what you want.
I will actually force myself to draw it.
You're welcome.
Yeah, the DVD screensaver.
Artificial sea war girl, what does it mean?
Right, I'm hiding it, I'm hiding it.
Right, next thumbnail.
After slime girls, I've completely forgotten.
Oh, I'm educating you in my special interests.
Which you're not ready for.
Which I'm gonna have so much fun making.
Like I need to do like a big powerpoint presentation.
That stream is gonna be so long.
If I get carried away, that stream's gonna be so long.
Okay, next one.
Making her successors in Gen 2.
The goblino reefling girl.
A reefling girl version?
I feel like you guys are a reflection of me though.
I was gonna get a model update so I can lift up my bangs,
my fringe, and then reveal the nicotine patch on my head as well.
I love strony calls, I love strony calls.
Thank you, I love reefling.
Cuddles.
Cause that's your surname.
Strony, what kind of...
No, my autistic special interests.
Not those kind, not those kind of special interests.
The autism kind.
I'm gonna talk about seat dispersal.
I'm gonna talk about digestive tract.
I'm gonna talk about
socialization.
I'm going to talk about what life was like before capitalism.
I'm gonna talk about region locked capitalism,
which is feudalism.
I can never say it right.
I'm also gonna talk about Freud.
You know, because he was kind of right
and people shunned him.
I'm gonna talk about what mother's special interests are.
The other special kinds are in a different stream.
Feudalism, that's a feudalism.
What kind of seats?
I'm gonna teach you about seats in general,
so you can learn.
I'm gonna teach you about how farming works
and agriculture and that kind of thing.
Freud was ahead of his time, honestly.
That man was onto something and they shunned him
all because he had a cocaine addiction, okay?
What else are we gonna talk about?
Probably
world war accounts.
Some information that you might not have known.
I'm gonna talk about the farming.
How farming at home has disappeared.
Planting at home and growing your own veggies
at home has disappeared.
More like Sigma Freud.
Sigma, I mean.
Freud had a big speech on how he took coke before
and then the only thing that mattered was he seemed smart.
Well, cocaine gives...
Oh, I really like drugs as well.
No, I don't take them.
I'm interested in the effects they have in the addiction
and the social perception of addicts.
Now, this is a conversation for the stream,
but I will touch on it now.
So, you know when someone says,
oh, that person's so addicted
that they couldn't give up the drugs for their kids
and then they're like, oh, that's disgusting, XYZ.
No, motherfucker.
That shows you how unbelievably,
like, the grip that the narcotics has on that person,
it shows you they have...
They are unable to reason.
It shows you how strong and dependent their body is
on this substance, motherfucker.
Listen up!
That's not how it works.
Literally, people be like, oh, she couldn't beat...
Like, you know, when you hear stories like, oh, he couldn't beat the addiction.
She couldn't beat the addiction for, like, his son, her son or whatever.
Oh, they're weaker-weaver.
No!
That shows how un-the-vice-like grip
that does not even give them an inch to breathe
that the narcotics has on them.
But anyway, I'm gonna get into that conversation
in my special interests.
So yeah, you're getting galaxy brain
because you're getting educated in my special interests.
What if we're addicted to you?
Um, hopefully I'm not detrimental to your health.
I hope anyway.
But look, it's me!
Hey, listen!
Listen to my special interests.
You will get to hear them all.
Where are you going?
You're wiggling away like a little worm.
Mmm.
But yes, I also talk about how to reverse, like, the effects of addiction
and how it should actually work and, like, how you do it.
Good night, mommy.
Gonna ink and go to sleep.
I love your honesty, Reefling.
Have an amazing inking session.
Please remember to say my name when you ink, okay?
Just a little stronger.
Okay, that'll do me.
Thank you.
Thank you. Good night.
Okay.
How many...
Wait, have I spelled it wrong?
Get educated in my special interests.
Oh.
Oops.
Should I leave it in?
Because it makes it more like me?
Me.
Okay.
Next thumbnail.
Right.
So then after you've been educated in my special interests, Reefling,
next, we are...
I actually don't know what we're playing.
Hold on.
Let me pull up my whole thing.
We're playing supermarket simulator.
That might get exchanged if I am dumb.
And it's apparently a long game, which I had no idea about.
Oopsies.
That was a mistake.
Genuine mistake.
It was a mistake.
It was a mis-input.
Mis-input.
Puzzle.
Secret puzzle.
Revealing my thumbnail.
Secret, secret, secret, secret puzzle.
Wait.
Where are you doing a collab with Azura?
I am.
But you're not seeing the thumbnail yet.
It's a secret.
So this is my supermarket thumbnail.
No, you guys honing in on the text.
You guys are so smart.
They're like going straight for the text first.
That's so wise.
This is a really cool way to post your schedule.
Yeah.
I think I'll do a puzzle stream again maybe once I've got more behind the scenes art
work and stuff to show off because I think it's quite exciting doing it that way.
So I'll need to get ordering.
Chop, chop, scrawny.
Get ordering some more things.
So I gave my lecture to date.
Despite my lack of preparation, I spoke well and I ascribed to the cocaine I had taken
before and I told.
So cocaine is really interesting because it gives you an ego.
I know that sounds crazy because you know, you know people that are unconfident, you
know, we've all experienced something like that.
A mis-input.
I'm going to, I'm going to put something in this mess.
All right.
Okay.
That's actually really good.
You get, you have been awarded the comment of the day.
Congrats.
That was actually a really good comment.
I know I sound so sarcastic.
It's so funny that I can't laugh.
It's that good.
Okay.
What was I saying?
Oh cocaine.
It gives you an ego.
So when you're unconfident, often you will hear things such as, oh, you know, fake it
until you make it.
Say positive affirmations to yourself.
The substance cocaine gives you an ego.
It is the most bizarre side effect.
Truly.
Sam, thank you for the rose.
Why is your profile picture a pan?
Wait, that's not even a pan.
That's a walk.
Why is your profile picture a walk?
That's so specific.
Thank you, Sam, for the rose.
You're giving me flowers.
I appreciate.
Are we super chats?
I won't call it super chat.
There we go.
The booger sugar, honestly.
Freud was kind of cute, but it was a bit too much.
It was a bit much.
He did.
I think he did a really messed up experiment with someone's kids at one point.
And I was like, oh, Freud, steady on.
It's a skillet.
Isn't that a walk?
Oh, sorry.
He did.
And a lot of times the thing's not really scientific.
Yeah, I think there's a lot of things with Freud.
I'll do a deep dive.
I might also talk about Guy Fox because on the 5th of November, a guy called Guy Fox.
Yeah, his name was literally Guy.
He planned to blow up parliament on the 5th of November, but his plot got foiled.
So on the 5th of November, the UK set of fireworks for it.
But England celebrate it because his plot got foiled, but Scotland celebrate it because they...
Yeah, you know what I'm trying to say, right?
So fireworks on the 5th of November in Scotland.
Yeah, we were rooting for him.
He had the right idea.
It's a memorial day in Scotland that day for funny reasons.
For me, it ends up being microbiology and diseases.
Ooh, I could talk about diagnoses.
I quite like them too.
The only problem when you talk about diagnoses, especially when it's genetic disorders or whatever,
I don't want to use actual pictures of people because that's not very nice.
Maybe I can get medical drawings to be respectful to the identity.
I can at least forget Freud because he was the one of the early researchers in the field that was prey.
This is my supermarket simulator.
I say, bag your own shite.
So, I'm going to tell you one thing I don't like about you Aussies.
Ooh, that's right, Australians.
I'm calling you out at 6am in the morning.
No, the Australian etiquette is you do not bag your own items.
In Scotland, you bag your...
Put scrawny in the bag.
In Scotland, you bag your own items.
When I came to Australia and saw that people do not bag their own items,
I was mortified.
I watched the most impatient woman ever get her stuff bagged.
And I'm like...
And she was like, can you hurry up?
I'm on a time crunch.
And I'm like, just if you...
If you bagged it yourself, you would already be in your car driving away to your house.
Okay?
Are you squinting me right now?
Reflin for a month.
Thank you, little kawakami for the extended membership.
I appreciate it.
You're doing it.
Right, what comes after?
Keep forgetting my schedule.
As if I'm not the one who freaking made it.
And...
I'm doing ring fit.
Right, ring fit next.
Okay, this is a bit of a...
It's rather familiar, so don't be too surprised if you recognize it.
It's not much of a different layout, okay?
I confess.
I must confess.
I still believe.
Still believe.
Right, one more, one more, one more.
Oh.
Oh, okay, that was a little bit...
One more.
Thank you for the extended membership again.
Ritto!
I probably said your name horrifically wrong.
Bro, that was one thing about that collab stream with the girls.
I was saying everyone's name wrong.
Like horrifically wrong.
Bags are cashier exclusive where I live.
The bag, the stuff, I'll scan it.
Yeah.
It's a different everywhere, but I bag my own stuff.
Thank you, ladrian.
You sound like an elf from Lord of the Rings.
Ladrian.
Thank you for becoming a member.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, I bring a backpack, so I pack my own stuff.
And whenever I say to the person that's attending me,
I'm always like, oh, good morning.
I'm just going to pack it myself.
They're always like, oh, thank you so much, dear.
And I'm like, ooh.
And then I always explain, yeah, in Scotland you do it yourself.
Now, you can't ask for help in Scotland.
Don't get me wrong.
But if you want to be in and out of that shop,
as quick as can be, then I want more of the collab stream.
It was so funny and cute.
Well, let's review another girl.
I think we're probably going to do a tier list,
like an actual tier list at some point.
Now, and before fucking VTubers get their feelings hurt
because we're actually ranking them,
I'll do a meme-y to you, a bit of a meme side, OK?
And it would be like, would slap in between your thighs,
would lick them or something like that,
would put like chocolate cake on them or something.
I just want all the girls together.
Aw, you like when we hang out together?
I find it so fun.
I already know what the collab is in August,
but I'm not going to tell you because it's inside your secrets.
You're not allowed to know what the collab is in August.
Howdy.
Hi, Evelyn.
We're currently doing puzzles
and I'm making you unlock my thumbnails for the week via puzzles.
I love Stony Cuddles.
I love, I love Evelyn Cuddles.
Alright, keep your secrets, honestly.
Alright, then keep your secrets.
Was actually my night elf, George's name and wow.
Ah, and I told you it was Elvin.
And the USA.
I don't know.
Brian.
In the USA, if you want to bag your own stuff,
you just use self-checkout machine.
Same if you have social anxiety.
Ah, that's cool.
I like that sound.
Are you squinting me right now?
Uh,
Maurizio.
Did you forget to send a message?
You could have typed in that super chat.
Thank you for giving me your super chat, Cherry.
Right now.
How did I say that?
Maurizio Rosetti.
Okay, I can say that part good.
Thank you for the super chat.
I appreciate it.
And Sam too.
You know, there's self-checkout,
and if you want to do your own thing,
you can use self-checkout,
but it depends how much I've got,
but I put everything in my backpack,
because I rate a bake.
What are you doing?
Alright, this is the first time I think USA
have a good thing going,
sweaty mummy.
I hope you're ready for it,
because I'm going to be a load of anything.
I'm digging the background music.
It is a Lo-Fi Elden Ring?
No.
Legend of Zelda non-copyright.
Ta-da!
Ring Fito Avento de...
Where did it go?
I didn't find myself.
But that's it.
And look at my heart rate.
It's 1,380.
Oh no, it's 138 beats per minute.
I'm at the last.
I was like, how, 1,388?
No, 138.
I have no idea what my heart rate max
is going to be on the stream,
but we'll find out together.
Mummy in those thighs makes me want to ink.
Steady on.
Copyright Lo-Fi Zelda beats to make puzzles.
No, not copyright.
Non-copyright.
No copyright, okay?
Please don't perish from the heart rate.
No, I will look after myself.
Gamer chop.
My resting heart rate is like 90 and 100.
Damn, are you me?
But yeah.
Mummy looks cute in that outfit.
You like it?
You like my little headband?
I need to stick on her.
I like the way you do.
I'm like, there, there.
There's thighs though.
Okay, how many more thumbnails do we got?
Will it do a fit?
Right.
I will challenge you to 150 to see how unbelievably easy it is.
Eh, who is next?
Sakura game.
Okay.
Oh, this is ridiculous.
This is going to take like no time at all.
As long as you guys are having fun though, that's all that matters.
Right.
I need to lake.
I don't even think I'm going to have time to pin this.
Are you ready?
Okay, boom.
I don't even think I have time to pin it before you guys finish it.
There we go.
Replace pin.
Yeah, this is what 50 pieces is.
This is Suika and not Tsukiyo.
No, this is too quick.
I am Watamera.
Mummy's Melons.
Would you play with Mummy's Melons?
There you say.
You did it.
Replay.
Oh, almost.
Oh, we're getting edged.
We're getting edged with an edge piece.
Coco Melon.
No.
There you go.
Tsukiyo.
One big stretch.
Wow.
Okay.
I switched.
I'm jumping up and down.
Boing.
I'm up on the top corner.
I'm down on the top corner.
I'm up again.
I'm down.
I'm hovering over gently in the middle.
Oh, I'm in the other corner.
What am I going to do?
Oh.
Oh, I'm jumping in them.
I am diagonal out here.
Call me Diagon because I'm Diagon Alley Moving.
That's absolutely awful.
You won the last one to be a thousand pieces.
I don't even think something else is that good.
If you want it to be a thousand pieces, sure.
I'll do as you command my refling.
Your wish is my command, truly.
Okay.
Next we have Azura collab.
Thumbnail.
A thousand pieces and random rotation.
Are you mad?
Okay.
How about next time?
No.
Maybe we wouldn't do it this time.
How about next time we do...
What does that say?
Azura.
The servers are like pleased for the love of God.
Oh, Azura.
What the heck?
Oh, we're doing a call.
I'm making the reflings see the thumbnails via puzzles on stream.
I know it sounds crazy, but it's true.
I'm putting them to work.
Hi, Azura.
Azura, you have not slept.
I have not slept, so I know for a fact you have not slept.
Bad gateway.
Is this the wrong link?
I was secretly doing the two other puzzles, were you?
Azura, you have not slept at all.
You did such a long stream.
I don't even know when you went to bed.
I went to bed and I think you still kept going.
It worked, but we overloaded it for a second.
I love refling cuddles.
16 hours of league.
You broke the vod and then some.
Jesus.
I took a three hour nap.
You are going to be perishing during the Yumi Plus concert.
You know that, right?
You're going to be a piddle, a little piddle on the floor.
You're not going to make it.
This is me and Azura's thumbnail.
Azura and I, sorry.
It's not me and person.
Person and I is the proper English.
Sorry, I know it bothers some people.
I apologize.
I was raised in a barn, okay?
I don't know your customs and your ways.
Can I drink her?
Well, if she melted into a puddle.
I mean, if you want.
The pot's kind of calling the kettle black, here's the lures.
No!
I don't get sleep because...
Well, yeah.
Okay.
You know what?
Sometimes you're right, Riflin.
Sometimes you're maybe on to something.
I want scrawny curls to R word me so I can cry in the shower afterwards.
Hang on.
I don't think you can say that.
Before anyone says where did I spawn that from?
It's in the chat.
It's right there.
Before anyone says where did that spawn from?
Hang on.
You can say that, I lied.
Real?
No, you're not supposed to agree.
Why?
No.
Why would you cry?
He did, so it must be legal.
Twilight Princess music?
Yeah, you have good ears.
That Riflin speaks the truth.
Cry?
Cry because it's over?
So, baby?
When it comes to using me or I,
you just have to remove the other person from the sentence
and whichever one sounds natural is correct.
I don't know.
What?
Tiny Spiny?
Thank you for the tip.
Are you sure?
No, because it's like Azura and I are playing...
We were here.
I...
Hmm.
What?
We only cry because we stopped.
You think the devs read this at any point?
They're currently looking up what Strony Cuddles is
and they're being introduced to the world of V-Tubing.
Love my cuddlefish wife.
Aww, such a cute nickname.
I just want Strony Cuddles hugs her peak.
Yeah, so this is the thumbnail.
I've colour-coordinated it.
It looks green, orange, like my hair,
and then blue and purple.
Someone said Azura's hair is green,
but it's like a teal blue, is it not?
That Strony lover?
Me, for real, for real.
Why are you booing him?
He's right.
They probably have a bunch of resource usage
and they'll check later and wonder.
It's Meku colour.
So it's blue, right?
It looks cyan to me.
Is cyan blue?
It's definitely not teal.
Well, people were saying her hair was green
and I'm like, no, my hair is green.
Closer to green than blue?
I don't...
I see blue.
That was my old account, by the way.
All of that, me, for real.
Oh, shit.
I think we're timing it.
I think I broke the servers.
Hold on.
Wait, no.
Is it still...
Am I going crazy?
I thought this one.
It's like a sea foam green.
Sea foam blue?
Yeah, I thought it was blue.
I don't know.
Maybe it's my eyes.
But like, if you look at me, you can be like,
yeah, Strony's got green in her hair.
But if you look at Azura, it's like,
she's a kind of a blue-purple palette.
I want the Vealer Girls...
The R word, me.
Reflames!
You want us to run a train on you?
One by one.
Or we'll just take a plop at a time.
That's terrible.
I shouldn't encourage it.
I'm encouraging it.
I shouldn't.
It looks close to Aquamarine.
Aquamines blue water.
So, surely.
Surely.
Okay, and then after we've done Azura's stream,
we have Drumroll, please.
Mario Kart, which I am going to add you guys into it
because it's not got you in it,
which I don't like.
I want you in it.
Nope.
That didn't work.
That did work, however.
Puddle!
This is the second-last one,
and then I'm going off and redirecting.
I'm slightly blue-colorblind,
so I don't know, a fuck room.
We're as bad as each other right now, god damn!
Now, this is Mario Kart.
Are you squidding me right now?
Broly legend.
So, Strongly does the carpet match the drapes.
No, there's no carpet.
Oh, here.
Oh, wait, no.
It's carpet in my head.
No.
Yeah.
Wait, I get so confused.
This is an American term.
What does it mean again?
Carpet is below because curtains are above.
Right.
No, it doesn't.
I don't have anything.
Carpet's other one.
Sorry.
It's like an American sentence,
and I'd never hear it until I entered the internet.
Shocking, baby.
Are you posting it again, Anon in the chat?
I can see it right above me.
Orange Anon will call you because your text name is orange.
Love, Strongly cuttles, do I?
I do.
Love me, cuttles.
Love me, cuttlefish.
Love me.
Love me, Momay.
Love me, Dominatrix.
Love me, Yandere.
Love me, little sister.
And love me.
What was it?
Mezugaki.
Kuzugaki.
My Bratipolar mirror.
My Bratiprincess.
Is she your princess?
Is that that?
I see princess now.
Instead of Brat.
Thank you for the tip, frilly legend.
Well, speaking of wax,
you'll never guess what one of my Donathon rewards are.
Wahoo!
Himagaki.
No, kuzugaki means like shit-talking brat.
No way.
Yeah.
I was going to go to a parlor.
That would wax me and give me permission to record the audio.
I'm obviously going to tip the girl because not only does she have to look at my clam,
if you didn't know, when you get a Brazilian wax, you also have to present your derriere as well.
They do your derriere.
So I think I have to literally bend over on this table.
I don't know what's going to happen,
but I'm going to ask permission to record it for a Donathon reward if we reach it.
So that would be a very interesting audio to put out there.
Once again, I misunderstood when you said record.
It's going to be great.
I'd literally be like, wah!
I have no idea what it's going to be like.
Apparently it's super painful though, like the first time.
No, I'm not going to bring the 3D.
Oh, I'm going to freak her out with that thing.
The audio, not the visuals.
The audio.
Good thing I can do this puzzle one-handed.
Stop! No!
How can it not be painful?
Well, they say if you do it over time, it's not as painful like it isn't sore as sore.
The audio is more than enough.
Stop! That's terrible.
They say the more you do it, the easier it is for the hairs to be pulled out from the root,
because that's what you're doing when you wax.
You're pulling it from the root.
But the first time you do it will always be the most painful.
So I'm rather nervous, I'm going to be honest,
but I was going to get like a full wax like my legs, my armpits,
and then my clam and all that.
So I don't know how long the audio is going to be,
but I think it's literally going to be me going like...
So over time, you get an iron clam.
No! You're upgrading my clam.
Also, can you post pictures afterwards?
What? You want to see my hairy armpit before and then after?
I don't think that's very cheeky.
I maybe do a cheeky armpit picture, I don't know.
I'd be kind of down for that.
I was going to do a foot photo shoot where I do every interest for imaginable,
like wrinkly foot, oiled up, dirt outside, spread toes.
Like I was going to do a mega collage of everything and anything you could have wanted.
Like of, I don't know, more about the taco and the peach for me.
No! I'm putting them in a picture of a peach.
Well the more you do it the rarer it gets.
Imagine an adamantium clam.
It's so op.
It's a bit, don't ask them that.
They're going to say yeah.
My poor reflex.
Can that be considered a tazadivel?
Waxing speaks to me because it ingrown hairs.
Post pics of the wax strips.
I feel it.
Oh, I'm not sure about that one, Chief.
I mean, if you want to, I guess it's natural but I'm not sure about it.
The clam will be strong and tight enough to snap tentacles.
Oh, just inked his pants somewhere.
Praise be to Talos.
You'd be surprised how many, like the pheromone pet.
Let me go snap.
Right, I'm going to edit this so that's you and that's you and that's you.
Okay, deal.
So this one's you and this one's you and this one's you.
And then my accord with you.
Cute face.
Yeah, you're like my...
I can't get around the bend because I still don't know how to drift in that game.
I'm probably going to have to look up a tutorial unironically on how to do that game.
Can you also run me over?
Why would I run you over?
I'll run a train on you but I will not run over with you in an automobile.
All those racers, me.
Literally me.
That'll be me.
Blue shell coming at you.
No!
You want me to edit a blue shell?
Reflink coming at me?
That would actually be really funny.
Hold on.
Hold on, you're giving me oil up.
Who said oil up?
I've just caught that.
I want her to outward me.
No, don't use the interactive chat in a puzzle game to state your claims.
Okay, last thumbnail if I'm not mistaken.
It's not the most exciting.
I don't know what this game contains but you guys were like,
Oh, it's a sad game.
Okay, so you'll never guess what I did with the thumbnail.
At last but not least, please can I buy the wax strip?
Funny you mentioned that because I could have sworn I saw a tech talk about a girl that
made a hundred dollars because she used to sell her wax strips.
I don't think you're joking.
I don't think that Reflink's joking.
I'm getting nervous, okay?
I'm getting shaky.
The intimidation music shift.
Oh no, sorry, I'm not showing the screen.
Whoopsies.
Next thing you know, people are asking about Johnny's bathwater.
I wish I could do that but I feel like I'm like so nasty.
I want her to outward me.
No, don't use the alternative chat as well.
You both can't be started on both sides.
That's terrible, Reflink.
So I have to enter a puzzle chat to save by all things.
No!
This is terrible.
Alright, we're going to meet them while you're at it.
Alright, enough, enough, enough, we're getting too far.
I'm going to get this going to be limited ads.
I'm going to end up being demonetised.
Johnny being nasty and more like tasty.
I love this woman.
Love you, Terry Reflink.
Hi!
Join the queue for...
Okay, you're done.
Cutie.
Now you're in cutie.
What I need to do for mom...
No!
No, no more.
Filling the database with all these comments.
Honestly, they're going to be like one error that's going on.
Gennlain.
Johnny could probably make bank sale and use...
Used what?
Absolutely not.
Use pads.
Are you serious?
Are you guys vampires or something?
Absolutely not.
Reflink's kind of freaky.
Chat restraints.
Reflects the streamer through and through.
That's terrible.
Fine, no R wording.
Just go to town, though.
I'm going to hug this woman until she falls asleep and go flying.
Funny you mentioned vampires.
Is that going to be a teabag?
What?
Funny you mentioned vampire.
Is that going to be a teabag?
The pad is going to be a teabag for a vampire?
Ewww!
Stop!
Right, you've won the gross comment of the day, Reflink.
Congrats.
Don't...
Queeflings?
No.
Absolutely not.
You guys are not referring to yourselves as fucking queeflings.
Do I make myself abundantly clear?
Listen to the tone of my voice.
You are not referring to yourselves as queeflings.
Absolutely not.
Why not?
It is so cursed.
Don't worry, mummy.
We will always be your queeflings.
We love you.
I'm a queefling now.
Azura, don't encourage them!
Azura, no!
Azura, you're going to encourage them!
How many subs for a queefling meme ASMR?
I don't know how to queef.
I don't know how to do it.
Mods, panasura, mods, timasura.
Kidding.
Mummy being staring gets us going.
Call ourselves worst things?
No.
Queeflings...
No!
Right, I'm not reading that word.
If I see that word, I'm not reading it.
Do you understand?
Start practicing.
I don't have a word.
Yeah.
Name of...
Oh, that game.
Yeah, it's a tearjerker.
Absolutely not.
Oh, I'm jerking all right.
Sort of way.
I don't know what's in it.
You guys just told me it was really sad.
So I was like, okay.
Mods, panasura, Azura.
She has the wrench.
Only you and your admins can.
Oh.
She's immune.
Oh, you guys are fucking...
Oh, that...
Azura created the mods.
You can't ban her.
I'll literally...
Azura is your mummy.
How are you going to stop us?
Going to pin us down and force it out of us?
Okay, we're back to our word.
And that's more like it.
That's more like it.
If Strani became a muscle mummy, would we switch to beeflings?
That's actually kind of humorous.
I'll give you that one.
Strani after running a train on the reeflings.
She's a queer...
We're queeflings now.
Shut the fuck up.
Sorry.
Beeflings?
Wait, what else is going to mean?
Meaf...
Meaflings?
Beeflings?
When the reeflings are thrown pests on each other,
they become beeflings.
Because it's beeflinging.
Oh my god, what other words?
Eaflings?
Weeflings?
See, I'm looking at my keyboard to go through the alphabet.
Eaflings?
C-flings?
C-fling you across...
I see you and I fling you across the room.
D-flings?
Beeflings?
G-flings?
He-flings?
Sneeflings?
When the reeflings are sick,
I talk them in the bed
because they're my little sneeflings.
Oh, that's so cute.
With mummy numbs my ears,
I become a tingling.
Wait, isn't a tingling the things in Legend of Zelda?
Aren't they called tinglings?
If we get too cheesy,
are we called brieflings?
Oh my god, that's so good.
Fun reeflings go wee flings.
Sorry, that one was bad.
They hold short, they hold swords.
We call them sheathlings.
When reeflings are upset,
they're grieflings.
I'm loving this, sorry.
When the reeflings are gassy,
we become que-
No!
No, not that one.
Everyone else, everything good.
Not that one.
GG.
Your tight climb syndrome
made me queefing.
Yeah, I've never,
I don't know how to do it.
So, I'll look up a tutorial.
I'll look up a tutorial
and I'll do it.
Oh my god.
That was so good to end on.
Holy crap.
That's all my thumbnails for the week.
I hope you enjoyed that.
That was hilarious.
Oh.
That was so good.
Alright.
When mommy post audios,
we become stifflings.
Oh no, I have to edit the audios too.
I need to edit one of my audios
and one of Azuras today.
I forgot about that.
Right.
First, nap.
Second,
Umi plus.
Third,
maybe nap again
depending on how tired I am.
No, I got signed out on my YouTube.
Are you serious?
Oh, for god's sake.
Hold on.
I don't know why.
I seem to get signed out on my YouTube so much.
Hold on.
I need to look into the old.
I need to look into it.
No way.
Why does it keep signing me out?
I'm not doing anything against the law here.
Oh my god.
I don't think I can redirect.
I think I'm going to have to go on my other PC
because I have two PCs.
That's right, baby.
And redirect via the other PC
then come back here and wrap up stream.
Does that make sense?
Or should I wrap up now and disappear?
No.
Because I need to be on in order to do the redirect.
Man, this is fun.
I don't know why I get signed out on YouTube so much.
I don't know.
It's bizarre.
We are reeflings in strontiae.
Our words are...
No, no, no.
That's not why I called you reeflings.
I called you them because of the halflings
from Lord of the Rings.
You're not called reeflings
because I are a word you on a daily basis.
When in doubt, just assume YouTube hates me.
Yeah, honestly.
Oh my god.
I don't even think I have my outro asset.
I'm not even kidding.
I do have an ending screen.
Do I dare to use it?
I actually have an ending screen.
I think we're going to use it
for the first time ever.
Wait, so we're all our word halflings?
No, that's not why I called you.
Well, okay, ending screen it is then.
I've literally not used it.
I think I used it once for debut and never again.
A once in a lifetime event, I dare you.
Okay.
Thank you so so much
for having such a carry on with me.
I hope you enjoyed the artwork reveals
and the fun things that I did have behind the scenes
as well as my thumbnails and my schedule.
I thought that was really fun.
Please don't be.
I might do that again in the future
because it was like no download, no hassle,
no fuss, no nothing.
Thank you for puzzling with the puzzles all over you.
My puzzle league flings, I tried.
I'm sorry.
I love Winston.
I love you.
Love you.
Thank you for enjoying stream.
I might do that again.
If I get more behind the scenes stuff
that I can kind of leak via a puzzle
because I find that absolutely hilarious.
I don't know why.
It's tickling my pickle in a very good way.
Okay.
That was so fun.
Thank you for hanging out.
Next week's stream snipe game is Mario Kart.
I am going to be going live again today.
To watch the Yumi Plus concert.
I'm just going to make sure.
I'm just going to make sure what time it's at.
Okay.
It's at 10 a.m.
So if I go to bed right now,
I can get a cheeky two hour sleep.
Can I tickle your pickle and push the naughty over?
No.
Two weeks.
Give me two weeks.
And then all the thought already begins again.
You give me two weeks and I'll start cooking all over again.
But yes, that was so fun.
Thank you for hanging.
Thank you for lurking.
Thank you for doing puzzles.
Again, Azura came in and did puzzles at one point as well.
I'm going to use my ending screen.
I cannot believe it.
And then I'm going to run and boot up my PC
and then actually redirect into someone.
Is she be live right now?
She better be.
She be cotton bum.
You better be live right now.
I'm going to spank you.
Is there no VR lure girl live?
Oh no.
This can't be.
Oh.
Well, if there's no VR lure girl live,
I'll just...
I'll go live.
Are you going live?
What are you going to play?
Don't say legal legends.
I've redirected into legal legends too many times Azura.
You're getting spanked for it.
What are you going live with?
You want that too?
DEMPA's doing a...
I can't...
Don't do it.
She's going to play League again.
Azura, you were showing off your skins at one point
and you were telling us about your favourite character.
I've forgotten their name.
But they kind of looked like you.
And I was like...
Oh.
Because they had like big blue hair.
DEMPA's live right now?
One, two inches.
DEM...
I went to bed this morning.
Azura's still going.
She is addicted.
Coming for my endurance title.
How dare you Azura.
Are you actually going live?
Or will I redirect into DEMPA?
If it's DEMPA's birthday, I'll go redirect into DEMPA.
Azura's legalings?
Honestly.
No, no, I was joking.
No live.
I was going to say,
you need rest before this little watch long.
I'm teasing, I'm teasing.
Right, I'm going to go redirect into DEMPA
because it's her doughnathon.
You'll need to give me like two minutes to run
and put up my computer and get it set up.
Is this fucking...
I have no idea.
I have...
Oh, wait, hold on.
Hold on, we have a...
Oh, pause, pause.
We might not need the ending screen at all.
I repeat, ladies and gentlemen,
we might not need that ending screen at all.
It will remain a mystery.
You have even...
You have yet to see...
You have yet to actually see
my stingers as well.
I was accessing my files yesterday
because I was having to send stuff to my editors,
Arisa, and I was looking at the files
and I saw my stinger and I'm like,
I have yet to show my actual stingers.
I have credit on the website
for the people who made my stingers,
but the actual stingers...
Are you trolling me?
Did you say DEMPA is live?
When she...
No one is live!
Upcoming, upcoming.
I don't see one live person
that I'm subscribed to.
I think they said DEMPA was live.
Is she live on Twitch?
Did you think I could redirect on Twitch?
Are you trolling me?
Oh, she is live.
What the fuck?
Why did that not show up?
That's so dumb.
Sorry, it never showed up for some reason.
You were telling the truth.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, do you actually want to see
the ending screen, to be honest?
Okay, I'll show you the end.
She is though.
Sorry, it wasn't displayed.
I don't know.
There are a lot of things displayed at once.
You think we're that dumb?
Well, I'm dumb
and sometimes chat's the reflection
of this dreamer,
so what does that make two of us, huh?
Okay, I'll show it.
Thank you so much for hanging out
with me, Reeflings.
Tomorrow, we will be drawing
your stinky gen 2 suggestions.
So please keep that in the back of your mind.
You're welcome to submit it via Marshmallow,
or you can do it live in the chat.
But if you do Marshmallow,
I can probably mentally prepare a bit better
for what I'm going to draw.
So don't be afraid to use Marshmallows.
Thank you so, so much.
I'll see you good for givers tomorrow
and I'll put up all my wait rooms and all that.
No, I'll see you in Yumi Plus Concert.
Give me two...
Three hours.
Three hours, I'll see you in Yumi Plus Concert.
Okay, I'll be singing and stuff, okay?
And then we're going to take notes
and then I'm going to ask Yumi Plus and be like,
hey, how the fuck did you do that concert?
Because I want to do it for my girls.
Okay, thank you so, so much.
I'll see you later today, Reefling.
But please enjoy Dampock
because it's her little birthday.
Even just lurking in the shadows is helpful, okay?
Bye-bye!
Time to use my end screens.
Oh, who goes there?
I need to...
Alright, can you hear me?
Okay, you can.
This is my actual streamer's ending scene.
Ta-da!
I did it.
I had to censor it because...
Yeah, it's very...
It's very OP.
Now, let's meet and look at you on my head
with your nicotine patch
and we both have hypnosis toggles
because you can technically hypnotise me too, Reefling.
Did you not know that about your lore?
That you're naughty and you hypnotise me sometime?
Hmm?
Yeah.
Yes, I have Butt Fangs and I have Booba
and I had to cover it.
Don't forget to like and subscribe
for the other industry.
She's actually...
It's true, it's real.
Okay, I'll test out the stingers
at another date, okay?
Need to give us a hypno-ending streamer.
Yeah, you like it?
Well, we're listening to...
Lea Jean de Zelda, but yeah.
We usually don't have to
since you prefer the backfire scenario.
Honestly, I love it.
Shove a mirror in my face.
I'm going to be right back
writing a new marrow right now.
Okay.
I don't want to go yet.
I'm really enjoying today's stream.
That was really fun.
I enjoyed that.
I don't know.
I like when we do stuff together.
Does that make me a weirdo?
No.
It makes me in love with you.
Thank you.
That was a really pleasant...
I know you can't see my model right now,
so I'm just trying.
That was an incredibly fun stream.
I thoroughly enjoyed that.
I really like when we can hang out like that.
And I look forward to doing it more.
Yes, I'll get going.
I'm going to go for a little chicken nap.
Maybe squeeze out a little chicken,
a little for bread while I'm at it.
And then we can watch Yumi Plus together
and take notes.
Love you too, dismembered voice.
Literally, you can't even see my wee model.
Spends like a ridiculous amount of money on model.
Doesn't even use it and just chats on the end and screen.
But yeah, it's a really good loop.
The loading screens were made by YumiYumiWorks.
They were fantastic.
They were such a good sport about everything.
I was like, it is paramount that reeflings are with me.
Because at first I was going to be the only one
that had their mascot in their loading screen.
You're not giving me money because I used my...
I will send you...
I will do the stingers tomorrow, okay?
I will do them tomorrow.
I need to send them to this PC because they're on my other PC.
I will show you what my stingers look like tomorrow.
Don't give me money for that though.
Thank you, Murizyo for the five.
Don't give me money for doing stuff that an average streamer does.
What's that letter in the middle?
An O?
Strong E?
Stip, writ, awe, knit, net, eh?
Unless I'm not understanding.
It feels like I can still hear her voice.
Pepe hands.
No, that was really fun.
We'll try Mario Kart.
See what's going on.
We'll know the world is truly ending when a stream starts
and she's using the starting.
That's when you know, literally,
censor hate is always hypnotizing us.
Stranny.
I wonder what's behind the veal or what.
My butt fangs.
You're not really supposed to be showing butt fangs,
but I have butt fangs.
So does Mercy actually.
She's broken as I hear her in my head.
Stranny.
Stranny Gonzalez.
Forget speedy Gonzalez.
One minute fifty-six beat my record right now.
Hello.
I'm about to go.
Stream's ending.
I'm just trying to shake.
Bansley give butt fangs, yes.
I'm gonna see, maybe Nari might work on a nude model for me.
I'm not sure.
I haven't been drawn nude.
But maybe Nari'll entertain me.
Entertain me.
Stay with me.
La la la la la la la la
feeling.
And those are not the words at all,
I have no idea what the words are.
Um, actually funny you mention stay with me
that song by the way?
That, I'm making a short about that song.
The, I don't know how you did that,
but anyway.
The thought of that making me unwhysed.
Yes.
And we're probably at the karaoke where Dad goes away too.
I think I'll do ASMR, bathtub is my first stream.
And then I'll do membership karaoke
just to really give my voice the wham bam
so I have no voice at all.
You have butt fangs?
What coincidence?
I also have fangs and they should meet your butt.
Congrats again on 10k, thank you.
That video propelled us ahead.
That person, that clip, did that highlight reel?
Like fucking threw us ahead.
I'm not listening, right?
I'm going offline, I'm going offline.
Thank you for the very kind and super chat
if it's on YouTube or still a tip, okay?
Thank you for your tip.
Maurizio, I'm absolutely butchering your name, Maurizio.
Okay, I'm going to go for a nap.
I will see you in three hours, okay?
Too many is three hours, okay?
Enjoy your nap.
If you want to nap with me, you can nap with me.
I'm not going to say no.
Bye-bye, strongy, bye, reef flings.
I read that, but I'm not saying that.
He's distracted by something.
Mods, get that man.
Okay, good night, I, no, no, good night.
Later, three hours, for goodness sake, woman.
Three hours, enjoy denpa.
Right, give me a big kiss.
Mm.
Three hours, see you in three hours.
No, good night, stop it, you're confusing me.
But I'm going to bed for a nap, but see you in three hours.
Okay, bye.
Bye-bye, bye.